mes chers collègues bonjour à tous C'est
avec plaisir que je rejoins
temporairement la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
vous vous présentez aujourd'hui un texte
dans l'origine remonte notamment à mon
élection au printemps en 2022
en effet dès ce moment j'ai considéré
qu'il serait primordial de me pencher
sur le sujet des jeunes et des réseaux
sociaux dans cette problématique me
paraît avoir pris un caractère
incontournable voire préoccupant ces
dernières années
le sujet est sans conteste l'un des
enjeux majeurs de notre temps cette
proposition de loi vise à s'y atteler
avec humilité certes mais non sans
ambition
en effet j'ai choisi que ce texte sur
lequel je travaille avec mon équipe
depuis plusieurs mois et je tiens à les
en remercier soit inscrit dès la
première journée réservée à l'ordre du
jour du groupe dont j'ai l'honneur
d'être le président
il me semblait nécessaire de proposer
une initiative législative susceptible
de lancer ici un véritable débat sur ces
questions et d'accompagner ainsi un
débat public qui je le sais a déjà lieu
dans les grands médias comme au sein des
familles
les parlementaires doivent assumer et y
prendre leur part toutes leurs parts je
suis bien conscient qu'un véhicule
législatif aussi modeste ne permet pas
d'embrasser toutes les tendues des
problématiques soulevées par les réseaux
sociaux la proposition que je vous
soumets n'est pas infaillible
et nous sommes face à des acteurs
puissants
j'espère bien avec votre concours à
porter une pierre non négligeable à la
construction d'une meilleure protection
des jeunes sur les réseaux
en proposant un texte ciblé sur les
réseaux sociaux et rendu plus
opérationnels grâce aux auditions et
consultations menées je pense que cet
objectif peut être atteint grâce à un
effort transpartisant sur un sujet dont
nous nous ressentons tous
l'urgence des enjeux
aujourd'hui l'âge moyen d'un autre pays
de la première possession d'un écran
individuel et personnel et de 9 ans et 9
mois
il ne s'agit pas ici de le déplorer ni
d'avoir un discours moralisateur ou de
condamner des usages de plus en plus
répandus parmi les jeunes je pense qu'il
s'agirait là d'une position non
seulement dépassée mais surtout
inefficace
toutefois nous devons prendre conscience
d'abord de la précocité de plus en plus
grande de cette puberté numérique mais
aussi de la puissance des outils mais à
disposition de nos jeunes littéralement
dans leur poche
cela implique de ne pas nous contenter
d'observer les potentiels dommages si
tenter que nous le fassions ce qui n'est
toujours pas le cas et la proposition de
loi vise aussi à remédier à cette lacune
nous devons agir pour poser des
garde-fous indispensables à leur
protection
nos sociétés sont désormais confrontées
à double défi de santé publique et de
protection de l'enfance
le constat posé par l'acnil en 2021 et
sans appel
nous assistons à la massification et à
une autonomisation des pratiques
numériques chez les jeunes publics
82 % des enfants de 10 à 14 ans se
rendent régulièrement sur Internet sans
leur parent
contre 95% pour les 15 17 ans
70% des enfants de tout âge regardent
seuls des vidéos sur Internet
s'agissant des réseaux sociaux la CNIL
constate que la première inscription
semble intervenir en moyenne vers 8 ans
et demi et que plus de la moitié des
disques 14 ans ils sont présents
face à ces constats il existe une
sous-estimation structurelle par les
parents des activités numériques de
leurs enfants l'Observatoire de la
parentalité et de l'éducation numérique
Open et l'Union nationale des
associations familiales lunaf deux
associations que j'ai pu rencontrer je
les en remercie dans le cadre de mes
travaux fournissent là aussi des
éléments de diagnostic inquiétant selon
les parents les enfants de 7-10 ans et
11-14 ans utilisent respectivement en
moyenne
1,9 et 3,2 réseaux sociaux les enfants
en revanche évoquent leur propre
présence sur 2,5 réseaux sociaux pour
les 7 10 ans et 3,6 réseaux pour les 11
14 ans
ainsi les jeunes sont massivement
présents sur les réseaux sociaux et s'y
inscrivent de plus en plus tôt
mais ces réseaux bien qu'il puisse être
un espace d'opportunités pour des jeunes
utilisateurs
sont aussi un lieu de convergence de
risque multiple
ces risques qu'elles sont-ils
d'abord celui de la propagation de
fausses informations et du complotisme
dont nous connaissons les impacts
profonds qu'ils ont sur la confiance
dans les institutions et les conditions
de possibilités même du débat
démocratique
les risques sont ensuite psychosociaux
avec l'accès à des contenus
problématiques voire dangereux
les sites pornographiques ne sont pas
les seuls lieux où les mineurs peuvent
accéder à des contenus de cet ordre qui
sont également diffusés parfois sur des
réseaux sociaux
mais il ne faut pas négliger l'impact
psychologique de contenu apparemment
plus anodins mais qui creuse leur sillon
dans l'estime de soi des adolescents et
adolescentes que penser en effet de
l'explosion des demandes de chirurgie
esthétique ils ont à se rapprocher des
images véhiculer par les filtres offerts
par les réseaux sociaux et pire encore
des cas d'adolescents conduits au
suicide par des algorithmes les
enfermants dans des spirales de contenu
délétères et je veux avoir une pensée
pour la jeune Molly Russell dans le cas
fait grand bruit au Royaume-Uni comment
ne pas mentionner enfin les trop
nombreux cas de cyber-harcèlement en
milieu scolaire prolongation du
harcèlement qui ne connaît aucun répit
aux issus aussi parfois dramatiques
l'actualité nous le rappelle trop
souvent
la nature addictive des réseaux sociaux
inscrits dans leur modèle économique
même doit nous pousser nous adultes à
mieux protéger les mineurs et
particulièrement les moins de 15 ans
encore plus vulnérables des potentiels
effets néfastes évoqués ici et qui ne
sauraient résumer j'en suis convaincu
l'expérience vécue dans ces espaces
il s'agit pour chacun par an entreprise
jeune de prendre ses responsabilités
pour cela les limites doivent être
clairement posées et rappeler et leur
dépassement doit également plus
franchement sanctionné c'est le sens de
cette proposition de loi son premier
article visa inscrire à notre droit
national la définition des réseaux
sociaux et ça m'a adopté par l'Union
européenne au sein du Règlement sur les
marchés numériques le DMA
nous semble important bien que le
règlement soit d'application directe de
reprendre cette définition dans le droit
national afin de renforcer la sécurité
juridique dans son application et de
garantir son utilisation
ultérieure dans d'autres champs que
celui délimité par le DMA
cette définition suffisamment large pour
tenir compte de la grande diversité des
réseaux sociaux nous paraît devoir être
reprise très fidèlement
les travaux menés ont toutefois conduit
à vouloir modifier le lieu de son
insertion dans le droit national cela
permettra de renforcer son caractère
opérationnel et de mieux respecter le
champ de compétences respectives des
différentes autorités de régulation je
porterai un amendement ce sens
deuxième article de la proposition de
loi vise à renforcer l'obligation de
moyens à laquelle sont soumis les
réseaux sociaux dans la vérification des
conditions d'âge et d'autorisation
parentale pour les mineurs de 15 ans là
aussi je porterai un amendement
proposant une nouvelle rédaction afin de
garantir la plaine effectivité du
dispositif notamment en la sortie sang
d'une sanction qui ne figure pas dans le
texte initial il s'agira également de
mieux contrôler les dispositifs
techniques de vérification invoquées par
les réseaux sociaux en les soumettant un
référentiel élaboré par les autorités
administratives compétentes
ce deuxième article constitue le cœur de
ma proposition
ils vise à mettre un terme aux
inscriptions de mineurs de 15 ans sur
les réseaux sociaux sans qu'une
autorisation express d'un détenteur de
l'autorité parentale était donnée et NTT
sérieusement contrôlée par les réseaux
troisième article de la proposition doit
viser de meilleures armes à la justice
pour lutter contre la haine en ligne à
cet effet le texte initial de la
proposition prévoyait une sanction
renforcée en cas d'absence de réponse
des réseaux aux réquisitions judiciaires
dont j'ai souhaité après les auditions
et la consultation de la Chancellerie
qu'elle puisse évoquer pour parvenir à
un dispositif tout à la fois mieux
proportionné plus efficace et conforme
au plus récentes évolutions du droit
européen quand elle conduira même à
anticiper trois ans la mise en oeuvre ce
sera le sens de l'amendement que je vous
présenterai sur cet article
enfin l'article 4 vise à demander un
rapport au gouvernement sur les
conséquences de l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux sur la santé physique et
mentale des jeunes la littérature
scientifique sur les dangers des réseaux
pour les jeunes est aujourd'hui
insuffisante ce que l'Organisation
Mondiale de la Santé a d'ailleurs
récemment elle-même reconnue
si un rapport produit par le
gouvernement ne saurait se substituer et
de production universitaire j'estime
qu'il s'agit là d'un appel solennel à un
travail sérieux d'état des lieux des
connaissances disponibles qui pourra
déboucher sur une nouvelle impulsion en
vue des publications scientifiques
souhaitées
mon objet ici donc pas d'envisager les
réseaux sociaux par le seul angle
répressif mais bien d'entamer ensemble
une réflexion globale sur les effets que
leur fréquentation a sur notre jeunesse
et de préserver celle-ci des risques les
plus patins en posant et en faisant
appliquer de juste garde-fou cette
démarche devra s'accompagner par
ailleurs d'effort dans l'éducation aux
médias dont je sais que deux collègues
vous expliqueront les enjeux aujourd'hui
même mes chers collègues cette
proposition de loi peut constituer une
réelle avancée pour la protection
améliorée des jeunes dans leurs usages
des réseaux sociaux et elle permettra de
mettre chacun face à ses obligations et
à ses responsabilités je suis convaincu
que cet enjeu peut ce matin nous
rassembler de façon très large au-delà
de nos clivages et vous remercie d'ores
et déjà pour les nombreuses propositions
d'amélioration du texte porté par vos
amendements je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour cette
présentation claire et luminaire de
votre proposition de loi maintenant je
vais donner la parole aux orateurs de
groupe pour 4 minutes et nous commençons
par Béatrice Piron pour le groupe
Renaissance
oui c'est bon vas-y merci madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues premièrement je tenais à
remercier Laurent marquandelli
rapporteur de cette proposition de loi
de s'être emparée de la question de la
protection de nos jeunes sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui le constat est sans
appel 82 % des enfants de 10 à 14 ans
vont régulièrement sur Internet sans
leurs parents et 63% des moins de 13 ans
ont au moins un compte sur un réseau
social alors que cela n'est pas autorisé
nos enfants sont donc exposés de plus en
plus précocément aux écrans et de ce
fait au contenu inapproprié qu'ils
peuvent rencontrer sur les réseaux
sociaux face à ces dérives la majorité a
mis en place depuis le dernier mandat
plusieurs dispositifs juridiques afin de
protéger nos jeunes c'était le cas dès
2018 dans la loi sur l'encadrement de
l'utilisation du téléphone portable dans
les établissements scolaires en 2021
nous avons légiférer sur le harcèlement
scolaire et les dangers du
cyber-harcèlement et les actualités nous
de vous interrompre quelques instants
parce que ici on entend pas très bien
donc soit il faudrait que il y a un
petit peu moins de bruit et que vous
apeuros aussi un petit peu plus du micro
parce que voilà c'est très compliqué
merci en 2021 nous avons légiférée sur
le harcèlement scolaire et danger du
cyber-harcèlement et l'actualité nous a
rappelé comment ces situations peuvent
amener à des drames en 2022 nous avons
facilité l'accompagnement parental sur
Internet grâce à l'installation par
défaut de dispositifs de contrôle
parental nous avons également mis en
place des enseignements numériques dans
les écoles dans les collèges les lycées
aboutissants des certifications comme le
permis Internet ou pics pour mieux
éduquer et informer nos jeunes enfin le
gouvernement a mis en place un site
internet intitulé je protège mon enfant
pour un gouv.fr afin de mieux informer
et accompagner les parents quant aux
usages de leurs enfants sur Internet
n'oublions pas de mentionner l'excellent
travail réalisé par les associations
telles que Y en France ou l'association
open l'Observatoire de la parentalité et
de lui dire l'éducation numérique mais
aussi les associations de parents
d'élèves qui œuvrent pour l'information
des parents à propos des déranger
d'Internet l'année dernière Adrien
taquet secrétaire d'état chargé la
protection de l'enfance à même lancer
les campus de la parentalité numérique
nous souhaitons donc insister sur le
rôle très important des parents dans
l'accompagnement de leurs enfants sur
Internet cependant selon l'étudiant en
France de 2021 83% des parents ne savent
pas vraiment ce que leurs enfants font
sur Internet et 57 courante pour cent
des parents affirme ne pas recourir un
dispositif de contrôle parental une fine
il nous semble important d'améliorer
encore la protection des mineurs sur
Internet et surtout sur les réseaux
sociaux qui aujourd'hui contribuent à
faire circuler des fausses informations
de la pornographie de cyber-assi
allemand aujourd'hui certains réseaux
sociaux ont déjà l'effort d'exiger une
autorisation parentale pour la création
d'un compte pour un jeune de moins de 15
ans mais cela être aura les réseaux
sociaux qui ciblent plus les jeunes ne
se satisfont trop souvent de la simple
déclaration de date de naissance car
elle ne se sentent pas contraints par la
loi bien qu'il n'existe pas encore
d'outils technologiques validés reconnus
par tous pour contrôler l'âge des
utilisateurs en respectant l'anonymat
des solutions basées sur l'intelligence
artificielle permettent d'estimer l'âge
en fonction du visage et semble émerger
seront sûrement disponibles dans un
avenir proche d'autre part notre
ministre Jean-Noël Barrault ministre
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications a
également énoncé annoncé dernièrement
l'aboutissement de solutions tierces
permettant une vérification efficace de
la majorité pour l'accès aux supports
qui garantit aussi le double anonymat
les différentes auditions réalisées nous
ont permis d'aboutir à des améliorations
de la version initiale de votre
proposition de loi à l'article premier
la définition des réseaux sociaux sera
inscrite dans la loi comme la confiance
dans l'économie numérique et l'art comme
deviendra l'autorité à l'article 2 donc
le rapporteur réécrit pour mieux
préciser les contrôles liés à l'âge
d'accès aux réseaux sociaux enfin le
rapporteur proposera une nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 3 qui nous semble
plus cohérente avec les projets de
régulation européenne et plus réaliste
afin de permettre le respect des délais
en fonction des priorités en conclusion
le groupe Renaissance votera cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
merci madame la députée pour le
rassemblement national Julien Oudoul
[Musique]
merci manuel présidente monsieur le
rapporteur cher collègue depuis une
vingtaine d'années les réseaux sociaux
ont envahi nos vies quelquefois pour le
meilleur l'information la communication
l'ouverture au monde malheureusement
quelquefois pour le pire la haine et la
violence et la haine et la violence sont
les mineurs les jeunes parfois les très
jeunes qu'il la subissent de plein fouet
surtout quand ils sont 93% à détenir un
compte sur un réseau social notamment
pour les enfants de 12 ans si les
parents exercaient un contrôle plus
strict notamment avant la limite
d'inscription de 13 ans nombre de jeunes
seraient protégés des dangers que
représente les réseaux sociaux les
contenus pornographiques les défis
stupides mais surtout dangereux et le
harcèlement en ligne c'est un fait nous
le savons alors il ne s'agit pas de
faire de la morale comme l'a dit le
rapporteur mais les parents exercent
presque aucun contrôle et quand même
près de 80% à déclarer qu'ils ignorent
savoir ce que font leurs enfants sur
leur téléphone portable comme c'est
mentionné dans l'exposé des motifs de
cette proposition loi chaque seconde des
millions d'images et de vidéos publiées
sur TikTok Instagram ou snapchat sont à
la portée d'enfants d'adolescents en
pleine construction intellectuelle à
travers ces dangers avérés se sont
surtout des conséquences parfois fatales
à la fois sur le plan physique et mental
pouvant mener dans le pire des cas au
suicide aucun enfant n'est préparé à
subir la violence surtout quand elle est
gratuite et en ligne permise notamment
par une masse de faux profil tirant une
certaine satisfaction malsaine harceler
des jeunes en raison de leur physique de
leur handicap de leur tenue
vestimentaire ou de leur liberté
d'expression on a tous le souvenir du
calvaire de la jeune Milan
et puis il y a l'isolement
paradoxalement de nombreux adolescents
se réfugient dans les réseaux sociaux et
déclare y trouver un certain réconfort
mais derrière un univers virtuel et
illusoire se cache aussi un monde rempli
d'externalité négative qui bouleverse
leur quotidien dans certains cas les
jeunes voient leurs résultats scolaire
chutés ne lisent plus d'une pratique
plus de sport ne voit plus leurs amis
leurs familles ils se coupent du monde
extérieur les réseaux sociaux ont un
impact non négligeable sur la vie des
jeunes vous le rappelez très justement
monsieur le rapporteur dans cette
proposition de loi près de 30% des
parents déclare que leurs enfants ont
déjà pensé au suicide dont la majorité
sont victimes de cyber-harcèlement
l'association y enfance qui gère la
ligne téléphonique 30 18 pour les jeunes
victimes de cyber-harcèlement alerte
d'ailleurs sur la hausse du nombre de
victimes de janvier à septembre 2022 ce
sont près de 25000 cas qui ont été
traités contre 19000 sur l'ensemble
de l'année 2021 4 appels sur 10 sont
liés à la sexualité du chantage à la
webcam au Revenge porn les filles sont à
ce titre plus exposées au
cyber-harcèlement que les garçons le
foisonnement des réseaux sociaux
proposant du contenu obscène et violent
qui ne sont barrés que par une demande
un vérifiables de confirmation d'âge
expose indéniablement les mineurs à des
contenus choquants pour répondre à ces
enjeux le rassemblement national avait
proposé en 2022 des moyens pour protéger
les mineurs des dangers des réseaux
sociaux notamment par le fait d'imposer
au fournisseurs de système
d'exploitation au fournisseurs d'accès
d'intégrer un contrôle actif des
contenus explicites et des applications
soumises à un âge minimal par exemple
par l'obligation de renseigner un numéro
de carte bancaire c'est en ce sens que
notre groupe propose des amendements
visant notamment à prémunir tous les
mineurs contre le visionnage de contenu
violent ou pornographique si la route
est encore longue et nous le savons pour
protéger durablement efficacement les
des réseaux sociaux de leurs effets
pervers cette proposition de loi
permettrait une avancée indéniable c'est
pourquoi les députés du rassemblement
national la vautrons je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
LFI UPS Rodrigo Arenas la présidente le
mont change très vite très très vite il
est bien loin le temps où il suffirait
de faire figurer un petit rectangle bon
sur un écran pour interdire aux jeunes
l'accès à des programmes jugés néfastes
désormais tous 100 balles ainsi dès
demain nous aurons sûrement sur des
écrans des enfants plus vrai que nature
qui pourront faire tout et n'importe
quoi à qui on fera faire tout et
n'importe quoi également puisque ne se
seront pas précisément des enfants les
images virtuelles ont atteint à tel
niveau technicité qu'il est impossible
de faire la différence entre les images
des vrais personnes et celle de synthèse
il va donc nous falloir faire preuve
d'une grande imagination et surtout
d'une grande faculté prospective pour
légiférer efficacement car c'est bien là
notre problème faire avec des lois et
des décrets qui comme les écrans
deviennent vite obsolètes
nous sommes probablement tous et tous
d'accord sur les constats que l'on
retrouve dans l'exposé des motifs de
cette proposition de loi l'addiction de
nos enfants pour les écrans et désormais
programmés pensés par les fabricants
mercantile sans scrupules les réseaux
sociaux font maintenant partie du
quotidien de nos enfants et nos
adolescents on sent-il suffisamment
protégés la réponse est non et je suis
certain que nous partageons toutes et
tous ici cette réponse il suffit
d'ailleurs pour s'en convaincre de voir
tous ces faits d'actualité tragiques qui
font la une de nos journaux et le drame
des familles ainsi notre responsabilité
d'élus bien sûr mais aussi et surtout
d'adultes et de construire des réponses
appropriées d'élaborer des lois qui
puissent véritablement mettre en
sécurité nos enfants nous ne pourrons
pas avoir peur d'être contraignant
exigeants exemplaires quand la moitié de
notre jeunesse déclare avoir déjà été
victime de cyber-harcèlement de cyber
violence il paraît important de
légiférer pour surtout contraindre les
plateformes à mettre en place tout un
arsenal de mesure visant à protéger les
mineurs car ce sont bien eux les
premières victimes de ces règles
trompent peu contraignantes
la majorité numérique est une piste
évidemment intéressante même si elle
n'est pas simple d'imaginer le procédé
par lequel cela permettra de la mettre
en place sans contrevenir au respect de
la vie privée en respectant les données
sensibles des internautes c'est pourquoi
il nous semble indispensable de
renforcer cette proposition de loi par
d'autres mesures qui imposent aux
plateformes des actions complémentaires
tout ce qui permettra d'assurer le
bien-être de nos enfants doit être
retenu je voudrais tirer toute
particulièrement votre attention sur le
rôle que doivent assurer les premiers
protecteurs éducateurs des enfants à
savoir les parents ils le revient
prioritairement de contrôler d'une part
le temps passé devant les écrans et
d'autre part les contenus consultés par
les enfants nous devons bien sûr nous
occuper de l'impact de l'usage des
écrans quel qu'il soit sur le
développement physiologique des enfants
mais ce dont il est question ici est
davantage la régulation des contenus une
action qui passe en priorité par les
parents des mineurs tout d'abord pour
pouvoir valider le contrôle de l'âge des
enfants des jeunes qui s'inscrit sur les
plateformes mais aussi mais aussi pour
informer leurs enfants et pour
s'informer eux-mêmes il apparaît que 80%
des parents ne savent pas ce que font
leur enfant quand ils naviguent sur la
toile c'est un chiffre énorme que nous
devons nous attacher à réduire
le danger que courent leurs enfants sont
multiples mais ils n'en sont plus pour
la plupart pas le temps informé cette
information doit être diffusée par les
plateformes mais nous savons que cela ne
sera pas suffisant l'éducation aux
médias numériques doit être à
destination des enfants comme des
adultes il faut des programmes
pédagogiques qui soient développés au
sein de l'école et qu'il s'adresse aux
familles aux parents aux enfants et
parfois même aux enseignants c'est ça la
coéducation il faut également que les
parents soient en capacité de veiller
aux échanges de leurs enfants sur le net
pour lutter contre la haine en ligne
cela implique qu'il puisse être supprimé
leur compte s'ils estiment que les
propos tenus sur tel ou telle
application des raps car si cette loi
autorise les parents et inscrire leurs
enfants sur des comptes Instagram
snapchat ou Tik Tok avant leur majorité
numérique qui seraient fixées à 15 ans
il faudra bien qu'il puisse surveiller
et repérer leurs éventuelles
comportement d'addiction de prédation ou
encore de manipulation rappelons que 80%
des enfants français de 11 à 12 ans ont
un compte sur un réseau social vous
l'aurez compris cette proposition de loi
visa assuré la sécurité des enfants mais
nous pensons qu'il faut aller plus loin
pour mettre en place la majorité
numérique il faudra trouver les process
qui je respecte la vie privée des
mineurs et qui empêche la diffusion voir
la vente des données sensibles qui les
concerne nous ne rêvons pas cette mesure
ne suffira pas à elle seule à résoudre
les problèmes graves qui se posent à nos
enfants à nos adolescents lorsqu'ils
usent et abusent des tablettes des
téléphones ou votre écran nous-mêmes en
tant qu'adulte nous avons déjà du mal à
en faire un usage raisonné alors
imaginez nos enfants par nature
insuffisamment mature nous législateurs
de moins être au moins autant efficace
et inventif que ces entreprises qui vont
du rêve à nos enfants sans les prévenir
que ces usages addictifs peuvent
rapidement tourner au cauchemar nous ne
voulons pas d'une société tout entière
vouée à la marchandisation des
resigences de sociaux nous ne voulons
pas d'une jeunesse surconnectée
dépendante anxieuse entravée nous devons
être preuve à assumer des lois
restrictives et coercitives pour ces
entreprises afin que ces jeunesses nos
enfants soient véritablement libres et
heureuse nous réserverons donc notre
vote en fonction de l'évolution des
débats et nous remercions le député
d'avoir entrepris cette démarche
extrêmement difficile et ceci
socialement difficile aussi à
entreprendre merci monsieur le député
pour les républicains Maxime minot
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes d'accord
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux depuis
maintenant plusieurs années a fortement
transformé les relations entre les
hommes et notamment chez les adolescents
nous ne pouvons freiner cette évolution
numérique c'est justement ici ce qui
nous inquiète l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux n'a été que renforcée par la
crise sanitaire et les nombreux
confinements qui se sont succédés c'est
le cas plus particulièrement chez les
jeunes qui ont fait de leurs besoins
d'être vu et reconnus une obsession au
point malheureusement d'en modifier leur
comportement et de subir les
conséquences d'une société numérique
basée principalement sur le paraître
cette omniprésence numérique dans la vie
des adolescents pose alors une question
simple
devons-nous nous en inquiéter ces
habitudes sont-elles la cause des
problèmes que subissent les jeunes votre
proposition de loi en ce sens est
formelle mauvaise santé mentale manque
de confiance en soi trouble de la
personnalité dépression de nombreux mots
de notre société notamment chez les
adolescents ne font que s'intensifier
depuis l'apparition des réseaux sociaux
ce problème de société n'est pourtant
pas nouveau et de nombreuses voies sans
sont déjà alertées sortis de la crise
covid des États-Unis à la France
plusieurs tribunes sont venus coup sur
coup sonner l'alarme sur ce fait de
société important et inquiétant
pourtant les responsables politiques ont
fait la sourde oreille nous avons peu
fait sur ce sujet aujourd'hui nous
sommes confrontés à une situation que
nous ne sommes que trop peu en mesure de
contrôler qui dit contrôle discerne
contrôle parental mais contrôle imposé
par la loi et pour cela c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que cette proposition de est
aussi importante à ce sujet plusieurs
spécialistes notamment le philosophe et
essayiste français Gaspard koning ont
mis la lumière sur ce problème comparant
l'addiction aux réseaux sociaux à celle
de l'alcool
si Gaspar koning fait la logique entre
réseaux sociaux et alcool c'est parce
que les comportements des adolescents
sont similaires dans l'ivresse
alcoolique comme dans l'ivresse créée
par les plateformes numériques
des inhibitions agressivité gratuite
insultes facilité à la déprime sensation
de cohésion sociale ou à l'inverse
d'isolement euphorie images dégradées et
surestimé de soi et c'est ici que l'État
doit jouer pleinement son rôle bien
évidemment que toute personne majeure
peut dans le respect de la loi vivre
librement sa vie mais dans le cas des
personnes mineures l'État a un rôle à
jouer notamment dans l'épanouissement
intellectuel et social de l'adolescent
et cela passe bien évidemment par
l'imposition de règles et de contrôle
notamment d'une majorité numérique
actuellement de 13 ans pour les réseaux
sociaux et uniquement symbolique
cependant si le groupe les républicains
soutient pleinement ce texte nous ne
sommes pas sans inquiétude ni réserve
idéalement c'est ce que d'ailleurs notre
collègue Alexandre portier va vous
présenter dans quelques instants il
serait préférable de porter cette
majorité numérique à 16 ans au lieu de
15 afin de s'aligner sur le niveau
européen vous qui en tout cas cette
majorité qui est tant attaché à l'Europe
et à rétablir la position que la France
avait défendu d'ailleurs dans le cadre
des échanges autour de la création du
rgpd de plus ne nous interrogeons sur la
responsabilité des plateformes pour
parvenir au respect de cette majorité
numérique vous comptez sur les
opérateurs des réseaux sociaux mais
comment imaginez-vous légalement ce
partenariat et envisagez-vous un
contrôle restrictif du respect de cette
majorité avec par exemple des sanctions
éventuelles en cas d'abus constaté de
cette plateforme
car en effet rien dans la proposition de
loi ne mentionne la partie technique de
la vérification de l'âge donc on
aimerait effectivement vous entendre sur
ce sujet bref si nous craignons qu'il
soit difficile de faire respecter cet
alignement de la majorité numérique sur
celle des réseaux sociaux le groupe les
républicains en salut la démarche et la
volonté de prendre en main ce sujet de
société cruciale pour nos futurs
générations et soutiendra bien
évidemment cette proposition de loi
merci monsieur le député pour les
démocrates Laurent est-ce que negox
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur tout d'abord vous remercier
de consacrer une partie de votre niche
parlementaire à ce sujet si essentiel de
la relation de nos enfants au numérique
et plus particulièrement aux réseaux
sociaux comme vous l'indiquez dans votre
exposé 80% des parents déclarent ne pas
savoir ce que leurs enfants font
exactement sur Internet ou les réseaux
sociaux
on pense aussi facilement au pire
situation que peuvent entraîner cette
surconnexion des plus jeunes comme par
exemple le fait que 20% d'entre eux ont
déjà été confronté à une situation de
cyber-harcèlement ce sont autant de vie
fragilisés et de blessures de vie à vie
qui mine réussite scolaire confiance en
soi et capacité de scolarisation
ce sont des destins brisés et dans les
pires drames des vies et courtes
ce harcèlement place les familles devant
un mur ou plutôt devant des murs celui
d'un enfant qui refuse par honte de
parler celui des plateformes derrière
lesquels l'anonymous unité libère la
cruauté celui d'un État qui court
derrière de nouvelles pratiques toujours
plus addictives mais le numérique avec
lui les réseaux sociaux peut être aussi
une source formidable d'information
d'échanges de découverte et de
rencontres
votre proposition de loi est donc la
bienvenue car elle nous pousse à nous
interroger sur cette dualité d'Internet
les questions fondament fondamentalement
notre rapport aux réseaux sociaux
notamment pour les plus jeunes car pour
une personne qui n'est pas encore arrivé
à son cycle maturité Tik Tok Facebook
Instagram et Twitter regorge davantage
de pièges difficiles à éviter mon groupe
se réjouit donc du texte que vous
proposez aujourd'hui et qui pose des
bases raisonnables d'un contrôle des
parents sur les activités de leurs
enfants tout en reprenant l'idée irritée
du rgpd en effet à 15 ans en adolescent
peut déjà commencer à
alors que vous reprenez inutilement une
définition des réseaux sociaux que notre
droit national se doit enfin d'adopter
vous fixer également avant cet âge de 15
ans l'obligation de contrôler
l'autorisation des parents avant toute
inscription sur leur site pour autant
nous connaissons la complexité qui peut
y avoir dans la conciliation de
protection de nos enfants il a
faisabilité technique d'un contrôle de
l'âge voire d'un contrôle parental les
récentes annonces du ministre barreau et
Claudel nous montrent que des solutions
sont possibles et que la France entend
réussir à concilier protection des plus
jeunes et des données aussi nous nous
réjouissons que les amendements que vous
proposez aujourd'hui prennent en compte
cette nécessaire conciliation en
impliquant la réalisation d'une solution
technique pour tous les acteurs
institutionnels je souhaiterais
d'ailleurs savoir si vos travaux vous
ont permis d'entrevoir la faisabilité
d'un contrôle notamment en matière
d'autorisation parentale la loi de notre
collègue Studer avait posé l'année
dernière le principe d'un contrôle
parental auquel nous sommes très
attentifs
aussi de souscrivons totalement à votre
article 3 qui vient
utilement transposer une initiative
européenne les plateformes doivent
réagir rapidement aux sollicitations de
la justice en cas de contenu illicite
sur leur site il apparaît utile de leur
imposer dans la loi une vigilance totale
enfin notre groupe défendra des
abonnements visant plus précisément la
lutte contre le harcèlement en ligne les
réseaux sociaux pour constituer des
pièges de fausses informations et de
dénigrement y compris sur la réalité de
ce qu'est un corps et ses imperfections
il constitue des pièges à la haine à la
haine des autres et de soi-même ils sont
poussés par des personnes pour qui le
cyber-harcèlement n'est qu'un jeu et
dont il ne se disent pas bien les
conséquences c'est pourquoi nous
proposerons de donner une meilleure
visibilité au plateforme
d'accompagnement des victimes de
harcèlement lorsque celle-ci effectue un
signalement sur un réseau social nous
souhaitons également avoir plus
d'informations sur l'utilité de
fusionner le numéro d'aide au
harcèlement scolaire en ligne et en
ligne quoi qu'il en soit vous l'aurez
compris notre groupe soutien pleinement
votre proposition de loi et espère que
notre débat permettront d'avancer pour
encore plus de encore plus loin dans la
protection de nos enfants je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député pour
les socialistes apparentés il n'y a que
channise merci madame la Présidente de
monsieur le rapporteur alors que 63% des
moins de 13 ans ont au moins un compte
sur un réseau social qu'en moyenne 70 %
des enfants de tout âge indique regarder
seul des vidéos sur Internet que la
première inscription les réseaux sociaux
semblent intervenir actuellement en
moyenne à l'âge de 8 ans et demi et que
tout cela un impact fort sur la vie de
nos jeunes et notamment leur santé
mentale débattre de ce sujet et
bienvenue au sein de notre commission
cette proposition de loi porte donc deux
objectifs d'une part fixer une majorité
numérique et de l'autre contrainte des
plateformes à coopérer en cas de cyberli
pour ce faire elle veut d'abord fixer à
15 ans là je à partir duquel un mineur
et hop à pouvoir s'inscrire sur une
seule plateforme sociale en effet
aujourd'hui un mineur et à la fois
considéré comme incapable de s'inscrire
sur un réseau social mais capable de
consentir ou non à certaines
fonctionnalités annexes plus sensibles
comme la géolocalisation ou instruments
de cookies il est important de mettre
fin au décalage entre législation et
réalité en ce domaine la fixation d'une
majorité numérique dans votre article 2
et donc intéressant mais reste
relativement flou et ne a sorti d'aucune
garantie alors même que la CNIL a émis
plusieurs recommandations sur le sujet
comme l'encadrement de la capacité
d'agir des mineurs en ligne ou
l'encouragement des mineurs exercer leur
droit nous estimons plus prioritaire
d'accompagner et d'encadrer la pratique
des plus jeunes dans la usage des
réseaux sociaux que de fixer un âge de
majorité il nous semble même dangereux
de généraliser une majorité numérique
sans prévoir les garanties nécessaires
cette proposition de loi ne donne pas
non plus de précision sur les modalités
de contrôle de cette majorité numérique
est-ce que c'est le est-ce que cela sera
une simple déclaration une vérification
de l'identité comment dans ces
conditions comptez vous rendre
efficiente cette disposition
merci monsieur le député pour horizon et
à parenté Agnès Carrel
merci Madame la
prise
lorsqu’un offre un smartphone à un
enfant il ne mesure pas vraiment les
dangers auxquels ils veulent l'exposer
au nombre de ces derniers figurent les
dangers des réseaux sociaux en effet
l'acnil constate que la première
inscription se situe en moyenne vers
8h30 et plus de la moitié des 10 14 ans
ils sont déjà inscrits ces canaux dit de
divertissement et de création de liens
ne sont pas inoffensifs ils sont
responsables de nombreux troubles et
leurs conséquences peuvent devenir
dramatiques l'addiction constitue l'un
des principaux dangers qui guettent les
enfants en cas de surexposition ce qui
est rapidement le cas en découvrant les
réseaux sociaux l'enfant risque d'abord
d'avoir accès à des contenus appropriés
à son âge avec également des contenus
souvent mensongers ou trompeurs le jeune
se retrouve seul devant son écran pour
visionner des images qui peuvent être
violentes pornographiques faisant la
promotion des drogues ou de bien
d'autres dérives de notre société malgré
la soi-disant politique de ces réseaux
visant à protéger la sensibilité de leur
utilisateurs l'exposition a des contenus
complètement inadaptés et bien réels et
perman l'algorithme de recommandation
peut l'entraîner d'un visionnage d'un
simple match un match de boxe puis un
match de rue à des bagarres à des
accidents de rue à des violences
urbaines voire des meurtres sur ces
réseaux sociaux les enfants peuvent être
également en peuvent également entrer en
contact avec des individus malveillants
de véritables prédateurs pour rester
dans la minima et contacter des jeunes
mineurs ces prédateurs ont recours à des
stratégies variées dont l'usurpation
d'identité les conséquences de ces
rencontres peuvent virer au cauchemar
virer au cauchemar les réseaux sociaux
sont hélas aussi une porte d'entrée
aussi sainement il en résulte des
blessures indélébiles qui mènent parfois
à des drames enfin les publications sur
ces réseaux sont intemporelles les
jeunes manquent souvent de connaissances
et de compréhension sur les
arborescences de ces réseaux ne mesure
pas cet aspect intemporel de leur
publication elle reviendront tôt ou tard
les hantés comme de vrai boomerang la
notion de temporalité dans leur vie
amicale et affective n'est pas non plus
très présente il pense communiquer on va
se clos avec leurs amis mais nous
adultes nous avons que les amis
d'aujourd'hui peuvent devenir les
ennemis de demain les photos partagées
les nudes par exemple iront bien au-delà
de leur pensée de nos frontières ces
pièges se referment sur eux et les
entraînent dans une spirale infernale du
manque de confiance en soi de l'estime
de soi la notion de vie privée
d'intimité reste floue à leur âge et les
conséquences intensifiables
les méfaits des réseaux sociaux ne sont
pas toujours connus des parents qui
eux-mêmes publient trop souvent des
photos et des vidéos de leur propre aux
enfants les exposants à la récupération
de ces clichés par des individus
malveillants ou dans des buts lucratifs
en tant qu'influenceur le contrôle
parental est donc la pierre angulaire
mais les parents ne sont pas toujours
conscients de ces méfaits l'enfant lui
n'a pas la maturité de discernement
nécessaire il est donc urgent de revoir
l'accès l'âge d'accès au réseau sociaux
en France la majorité numérique pour les
réseaux sociaux est actuellement de 13
ans c'est également l'âge fixé en
théorie par les plateformes comme
Tic-Toc et snapchat pour s'inscrire sauf
que cette règle n'est que symbolique
puisqu'en 2022 62% des moins de 13 ans
possédaient un compte sur au moins un de
ces réseaux la loi Informatique et
Liberté a déjà rehaussé la majorité de
numérique à 15 ans la présente
proposition de loi que défend le groupe
horizon prévoit donc de l'étendre aux
réseaux sociaux afin de limiter leur
utilisation à des adolescents de 15 ans
à partir de 15 ans âge d'une plus grande
maturité cette proposition de loi va
plus loin elle s'inscrit dans une
dynamique de responsabilisation des
plateformes elle renvoie la question de
la mise en oeuvre du seuil d'âge et ses
modalités d'application à un décret prix
en Conseil d'État cette proposition
demande au gouvernement la remise d'un
rapport présentant les conséquences de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux sur le
bien-être et la santé mentale des jeunes
car les données dans ce domaine sont
très insuffisantes l'enfant doit être au
centre de cette problématique et reste
notre seul boussole voilà chers
collègues pourquoi il est urgent de
prendre ce problème à bras le corps et
je remercie le président Laurent Marc
Angeli d'avoir pris cette initiative que
l'ensemble du groupe horizon soutien
merci madame la députée
pour juste en fait régulièrement il y a
du Brouail c'est toujours très difficile
d'entendre les orateurs et donc
maintenant je vais laisser la parole à
Francesca pasccini pour les écologistes
du peste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues trouvez la
bonne recette pour la protection des
enfants vis-à-vis des dangers du
numérique n'est pas chose aisé quel est
le bon niveau de liberté à accorder aux
enfants sur Internet quel est le bon
niveau d'encadrement qu'il faut fournir
pour qu'il soit en sécurité qui est
responsable de ces décisions un emploi
douté les réflexions sur ce sujet se
poursuivront bien après l'examen de ce
texte et bien au-delà de cette
législature il est néanmoins bienvenue
que notre Commission puisse débattre de
ces questions la proposition de loi que
vous nous soumettez nécessite me
semble-t-il de bien distinguer d'une
part la philosophie du texte et d'autre
part sa capacité à être appliquée
efficacement pour qu'il produisent les
effets escomptés sur la philosophie du
texte vous indiquez monsieur le
rapporteur que votre proposition
pourrait être une avancée concrète à
même de faire reculer le
cyber-harcèlement entre jeunes mais
évoqué dans le même temps les nombreux
risques auxquels ils sont exposés via
les réseaux sociaux or ce qui se dessine
en filigrane de ce texte n'est pas tant
la lutte contre la haine en ligne mais
plutôt la question du juste niveau de la
protection des mineurs sur Internet ce
qui apparaît beaucoup plus clairement en
revanche c'est la question de la
responsabilité qui incombe aux
entreprises qui proposent des services
de réseaux sociaux nous partageons ce
qui nous semble être votre volonté
affirmer de manière positive dans notre
droit les règles qui régissent l'usage
des réseaux sociaux et redonner la place
qu'il devrait déjà avoir aux parents
dans le processus d'inscription pour que
les enfants puissent découvrir ces
outils plus sereinement nous partageons
également la volonté d'encadrer plus
fermement les réseaux sociaux pour
qu'ils respectent les dispositions qui
les concernent je conclus ces
considérations générales en abordant la
question de l'âge qui va certainement
nourrir les débats autour de ce texte la
majorité numérique pour les réseaux
sociaux est actuellement de 13 ans voilà
une phrase qui ré d'un article de presse
récent qui reflète une idée presque
communément admise et qui est pourtant
totalement fausse cet âge plancher de 13
ans nous vient de la loi Copa américaine
et n'a aucune existence en droit
français redonné à cette majorité
numérique déjà établie à 15 ans et donc
au droit français européen un cadre
juridique qui lui permet d'être
correctement appliqué est incontournable
à ce titre nous sommes opposés à toute
modification de cet âge dans le texte
actuel sur les enjeux techniques
maintenant il n'aura échappé à aucun de
nous que la solution envisageait
n'existe pas encore même si nous votons
cette proposition la question reste
entière d'autant qu'il ne s'agit pas en
réalité ici d'une seule solution
technique mais de deux solutions la
première devra permettre de contrôler
l'âge de tous les utilisateurs et la
seconde de collecter le consentement du
titulaire de l'autorité parental au-delà
de l'inquiétudes sur la capacité à
développer les ces dispositifs
techniques s'ajoutent les inquiétudes
sur la quantité de données collectées
lors de ces vérifications le principe de
minimisation de la CNIL en joignant à
toujours limité la collecte des données
à ceux qui est strictement nécessaire et
la vérification du consentement des
parents va poser un défi de taille enfin
le plus grand défi concernant cette
solution technique et sans doute que des
solutions similaires soient utilisées
sur l'ensemble des acteurs à ce titre
nous saluons l'amendement de réécriture
de l'article 2 proposé par le rapporteur
qui vise à donner mandat à l'arc comme
pour la certification des solutions qui
seront mises en oeuvre en définitive est
bien que la mise en place technique
reste une question sans réponse à ce
jour le groupe écologiste partage la
volonté du rapporteur de renforcer
l'arsenal législatif pour que la
protection des mineurs sur Internet
permise par le rgpd sont enfin effective
et même particulièrement effective quand
il s'agit des réseaux sociaux nous
sommes donc favorables à ce texte en
l'état cette proposition de vise à
protéger les enfants en incitant au
dialogue sur les Osages numériques dans
la famille nous vous alertons néanmoins
sur le fait qu'une solution
technologique ne serait suffire pour
répondre à des questions aussi complexes
ce faisant nous vous invitons sur les
rapporteurs chers collègues a considérer
l'intérêt de mesure visant à renforcer
l'apprentissage des bonnes pratiques
numériques pour l'examen en séance merci
merci madame la députée pour le groupe
GDR nups Frédéric maillot madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues la question de la haine en
ligne est une plaie qui ne connaît pas
de frontières et l'exemple le plus
récent et l'assassinat du professeur
Paty et nous montre à quel point cette
question est sensible et qu'elle touche
de manière directe et indirecte des
personnes mais surtout des vies car oui
aujourd'hui un simple commentaire une
vidéo ou un poste peut enlever et abîmer
des vies elle donne les smartphones les
réseaux sociaux ont donné un sens
matériel à l'harcèlement les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus le terreau pour
toutes les doléances et les invectives
et elles mettent souvent en
confrontation chez nous à la Réunion
dépend entiers de la communauté à la
réunion nous nous les appellent à la
haine sont aussi monnaie courante et les
réseaux sociaux sont des caisses de
résonance puissantes pour Smart
stigmatiser des individus dans lequel se
trouve notamment nos enfants cette
proposition là de loi contient certes
des dispositions visant à contraindre la
haine en ligne et elle pose par un
silence aussi la question du
cyber-racellement notre question notre
questionnement et donc la suivante à un
moment ou un collégien sur 4 a été
confronté au moins une fois à des
situations relevant de cyber-harra Salma
ne pouvons-nous pas agir à la racine et
imposer aux plateformes une censure dès
lors que des propos haineux sont
détectés au lieu d'agir un postéri comme
les dégâts
psychologiques et psychiques et
psychique sont déjà atteints nos jeunes
nous ne pouvons pas ne pouvons-nous pas
prévenir les délais évidemment long de
la justice qui viendra agir des fois
trop tard face à des cas de
cyber-harcèlement le cyber-racellement
est également une question à laquelle
les parents sont souvent démunis plein
de collègues on leur appelaient
autrement dit la protection des mineurs
et de doigts être notre priorité mais le
laisser aller à des plateformes comme
Facebook Instagram ou encore Tik Tok
pour ne plus jeunes représentent un
véritable fléau sur leur santé mentale
pouvons-nous donc nous avons
ayons ce qu'on nous avons nous des
leviers d'action pour permettre aux
parents de mieux protéger leurs enfants
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député pour le groupe liote Stéphane
Lenormand
c'est bon le Président Monsieur
rapporteur
des moins de 13 ans ont moins un réseau
social et la moitié des utilisateurs Tik
Tok entre 11 et 18 ans cette utilisation
exponentielle et particulièrement
problématique pour les mineurs cela
vient d'être rappelé par de nombreux
collègues au risque d'uniformisation des
comportements s'ajoute ceux d'addiction
d'accès à des informations privées
violent d'influence des tiers de
harcèlement de pédophilie criminalité ou
encore deux troubles comportement
comportementaux assez caractéristiques
aujourd'hui pourtant les contraintes
exigées par la loi de 1978 par exemple
ou la rgpd sont inopérantes
officiellement on l'a dit aussi les
réseaux sociaux prévoient explicitement
que les mois de 13 ans ne peuvent pas
utiliser leurs plateformes je cite une
d'entre elles nous essayons de rendre
Facebook largement accessible à tous
mais vous ne pouvez pas utiliser
Facebook si vous avez moins de 13 ans
fin de citation
alors pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire nous partageons
naturellement les préoccupations que le
rapporteur a exposé et nous saluons
l'existence de cette PPL qui aborde un
sujet de société qui est extrêmement
importante à la fois pour notre jeunesse
et sur lequel nous devons essayer d'y
apporter rapidement des premières
solutions par contre nous avons quelques
interrogations sur la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif et vous avez du reste
monsieur rapporteur était assez ouvert
sur votre PPL pour qu'elle soit
perfectible en ce qui concerne le
premier article il nous a parlé
nécessaire de préciser la définition des
réseaux au-delà des plateformes connues
que son Facebook Instagram Tik Tok ou
encore snapchat
les forums et les plateformes de jeux
vidéo sont inintégrés c'est une question
importante parce que les utilisateurs
d'un même jeu vidéo aujourd'hui
constitue de véritables communautés qui
s'étend au-delà de la pratique du jeu
avec des logiciels comme discord ou
stream pour en institut que et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur cette
dimension qui ne doit pas échapper à
notre spectre en ce qui concerne
l'article 2 je m'interroge sur
l'effectivité de cette majorité
électronique
j'attire l'attention mais vous le savez
tous que nos jeunes ont une grande
facilité à contourner les procédures de
demande d'autorisation parentale il est
aujourd'hui facile pour ces jeunes de
transmettre un scan de photocopie
d'identité des parents sans problème et
je me demande si le Conseil d'État
pourrait exiger d'autres moyens dont
sont décret pour vérifier l'accord
parental c'est un élément à mon avis
assez clé d'efficacité de ce dispositif
par ailleurs et combien même on
trouverait un moyen satisfaisant les
jeunes pourront aussi se connecter quand
toujours quand se connecter grâce à une
adresse
IP qui ne serait pas situé en France là
aussi ils ont une très grande facilité
ils peuvent se connecter via facebook
Belgique ou encore tic tac Espagne donc
l'obligation paratelle sera-t-elle
efficace c'est nouvelles obligations en
effet ne s'appliqueront pas sur les
versions ét des plateformes et je pense
que c'est une faille dans le dispositif
même si nous avons pas forcément les
leviers pour l'empêcher
et à ce titre on peut regretter
qu'aucune sanction spécifique au cas
d'absence de l'accord parental de soi
prévu par la présence de proposition de
loi c'est pourquoi notre groupe soutient
un amendement qui vise à renforcer la
PPL en ce sens par ailleurs il ne suffit
pas de contrôler l'inscription sur le
réseau mais il faut aussi contrôler
l'activité du compte cela signifie d'une
part qu'il faut contrôler les comptes
déjà existants et d'autre part il faut
contrôler de manière plus drastique les
moins de 13 ans là aussi nous avons
déposé un amendement dans ce sens enfin
concernant l'article 3 c'est bien de la
réquisition des réseaux sociaux dans la
lutte contre la haine en ligne qu'il
s'agit et non de la seule protection des
mineurs contrairement à l'état actuel du
droit à la proposition de l'eau à
l'avantage de préciser les délais dans
lesquels la plateforme doit transmettre
les 10 informations cependant monsieur
le rapporteur pouvez-vous nous dire quel
est le montant minimum que l'on peut
attendre de cette amende qui pourrait
venir sanctionner ce délit
monsieur le rapporteur je vous laisse la
parole pour répondre aux orateurs et
puis ensuite nous prendrons les
questions des collègues merci madame la
Présidente d'abord je voudrais remercier
chacune et chacun d'entre vous ou vos
interventions
d'abord il y a un élément de contexte
encore aujourd'hui dans dans Le Parisien
vous voyez que il y a la question de la
chirurgie esthétique chez les jeunes il
y a eu un tas d'articles qui sont parus
ces derniers temps
je pense que
[Musique]
comme chacune et chacun d'entre vous la
rappeler devant un sujet de société
majeur politique au sens
étymologique du terme
mais encore une fois je l'ai dit dans
les propos introductifs
que j'ai eu tout à l'heure
cette œuvre c'est une petite brique
on va pas révolutionner tout avec la PPL
que je dépose et à l'humilité me conduit
quand même à dire qu'il s'agit que d'une
noix de PPL niche parlementaire qui ne
peut pas embrasser l'ensemble des sujets
à ce sens ça donc d'entre vous ce sont
positionnés pour me questionner sur le
fait d'avoir resserré sur les réseaux
sociaux de pas ou voir ouvert le champ
plus largement je leur répondrai que
c'est un choix délibéré de ma part les
réseaux sociaux prennent une place
répondérante et que d'autres forums ou
le jeu en ligne on peut même parler de
la pornographie puisque vous savez que
c'est un sujet majeur et qu'une loi a
été votée en ce sens
j'ai préféré aujourd'hui resserrer
recentrer sur ses réseaux sociaux qui
comme cela a été dit tout à l'heure sont
une porte ouverte et encore une fois
serait quand même malvenu pour un
responsable politique et je pense que
vous serez tous d'accord avec moi de
cracher sur les possibilités qu'offre
les réseaux sociaux nous les utilisons
fréquemment fortement revanche les
questions qui sont posées dans ce texte
c'est la responsabilité effectivement la
responsabilité de la mise devant les
responsabilités de tous les acteurs
d'abord la première responsabilité c'est
celle
c'est celle des pouvoirs publics c'est
ça la mort de se donner les moyens
d'avoir les outils pour pouvoir encadrer
les choses
cheminots tout à l'heure parlait de
quelqu'un d'assez connu que j'ai
rencontré également dans le cadre de la
réflexion qui a précédé à la rédaction
de la loi monsieur koenig vous savez que
c'est un libéral au sens premier du
terme et il avait écrit lui-même
dans une note sur son blog qui fallait
carrément interdire les réseaux sociaux
au mineur
il allait au delà de ce que je propose
dans la loi et lorsque je l'ai rencontré
je lui ai demandé comment se fait-il
qu'un homme aussi libéral que vous
prône ce type de mesure et il m'avait
répondu que justement être libéral
c'était aussi un moment fixer les règles
mettre les limites parce que il saurait
tiroir de liberté si à celle-ci ne sont
pas encadrés en réalité c'est tout ce
problème que j'essaye de poser
aujourd'hui et c'est la juste définition
des limites que nous devons apporter et
placement du curseur il est toujours
très complexe donc beaucoup d'entre vous
se sont posés la question de l'âge
j'aurai l'occasion dans le cas des
débats sur les amendements de répondre
d'abord je souscris au fait que nous ne
sommes pas tenus par des règlements qui
sont étrangers
par ailleurs nous avons un certain
nombre d'éléments aujourd'hui
réglementaires légaux qui font partie
notamment du nomenclature à
international qui peuvent nous pencher
sur l'âge que je propose dans le cadre
de cette proposition de loi
j'ai également entendu vos
interrogations et elles sont légitimes
sur
la faisabilité du contrôle
et les éléments techniques
c'est un vaste sujet vous imaginez bien
d'abord je pense pas qu'il soit du
ressort du législateur de la loi
d'inclure la recette miracle dans le
texte pourquoi d'abord parce que
je vous l'ai dit la loi elle sera par
nature pas failli pas infaillible
vous avez aujourd'hui des techniques
visa à contourner les choses
mais surtout il y a des réflexions qui
sont menées au moment où nous parlons
parler de l'accès à la pornographie vous
avez bien vu dernièrement en lisant les
médias que suite à la loi qui a été
votée en 2020 si mes souvenirs sont
exacts
certainement assez rapidement des
évolutions en la matière et moi derrière
quoi je voudrais m'abriter pour assurer
les faisabilités techniques derrière des
organismes qui existent et auxquels nous
sommes censés avoir conscience confiance
mais chaque collègues il y a l'art comme
il y a la CNIL et ensuite il y a un
décret en Conseil d'État qui viendrait
préciser les choses il y a aussi une
autre question qui est très importante
et que je n'ai pas véritablement
évoqué dans dans mes propos introductifs
mais que je voudrais changer avec vous
c'est des fournisseurs d'accès
les fournisseurs d'accès et bien ils ont
des contrats avec des majeurs qui
s'agissent d'un contrat d'abonnement de
téléphonique ou d'abonnement internet à
la maison faudrait être majeur pour
pouvoir avoir la capacité de contracter
pour avoir un accès internet donc c'est
nécessairement un adulte représentant le
mineur qui a cette potentialité
juridique c'est important c'est
important de aussi se poser la question
de la responsabilité de nos quatre
fournisseurs d'accès donc sur la loi
française mais je crois que les
fournisseurs d'accès sont aussi
prépondérants demain dans la régulation
sur
un certain nombre de
sujets qui ont été évoqués et qui seront
traités dans le cadre des amendements je
vais pas alourdir parce qu'il y a des
questions qui sont posées par des des
collègues
moi ce que je voulais rappeler encore
une fois c'est que un
loin de moi l'idée d'avoir un discours
moralisateur et
ultra moralisateur sur la question les
réseaux sociaux font partie aujourd'hui
de notre vie quotidienne et je pense que
nous serons véritablement mal placé en
tant que responsable politique pour
venir les foulées au pied vous les
utilisons je vous l'ai dit fréquemment
certains d'entre vous ont rappelé je
veux remettre le parent au coeur du
dispositif
le parent son autorité
son information et je dirais que le
débat suscité par cette PPL modèle mais
ambitieuse enfin c'est ce que je pense
et bien il a vocation à interpeller les
consciences
ou pas aujourd'hui
se satisfaire du fait que chaque semaine
chaque mois vous ayez des faits divers
qui nous rappellent l'importance de
cette enjeu de société que sont les
réseaux sociaux sur la question et
ensuite je veux évidemment aussi non pas
déclaré la guerre aux opérateurs mais
les maîtres également devant leur
responsabilité
un moment l'état pouvoir public
doit mettre les limites comme je le
disais mais il doit également mettre
devant sa responsabilité l'opérateur
économique qui produit un service qui en
tire bénéfice mais qui doit également
assurer une protection minimum minimale
à celles et ceux qui ont recours à ses
services c'est un sujet que je ne sais
vous avez tout et tous évoqué et la
sanction évidemment il faut qu'elle soit
juste proportionnée et c'est aussi le
cas de débat que nous allons avoir sur
les amendements qui sont déposés pour
conclure je voulais vous dire encore une
fois
l'importance de la notre culture
scientifique à la matière qui est encore
très défaillante ça va pas été trop
évoqué mais sachez que vous avez déjà
une première génération de jeunes
adultes
qui sont déjà peut-être père de famille
qui ont grandi avec ces réseaux sociaux
je ne sais pas moi l'influence que cela
a sur leur vie quotidienne
donc nous avons une nouvelle génération
qui va être d'ailleurs je vous le
rappelle confronté à des évolutions
technologiques encore majeures les
réseaux sociaux tels qu'on les connaît
seront bientôt complètement dépassé
probablement à la vitesse où vont les
choses et il faudra encore s'armer de
nouveaux outils mais cette loi si
modeste soit elle c'est un premier pas
c'est un premier pas qui pourra être une
petite brique qui s'ajoutera à un
édifice plus large qu'il faut construire
tant sur le niveau national un autre
législation qu'au niveau international
européen et même mondial puisque vous le
savez il y a pas de frontière sur
internet donc plutôt que de laisser ces
opérateurs et ce monde très vaste
internet crée sa propre loi et vivre
selon ses propres usages je crois qu'il
est notre responsabilité effectivement
de nous interroger de débattre le débat
c'est très important et puis de proposer
modestement des solutions à amélioré la
situation je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur maintenant
je vais c'est la parole aux collègues
pour une minute Véronique Riotton merci
le mieux utiliser à la fois
l'émancipation et la protection de nos
jeunes face au numérique et les réseaux
sociaux à la délégation droit des femmes
et à l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes nous avons établi le lien entre
l'utilisation d'Internet finalement et
le risque d'être exposé à des violences
sexuelles sexistes en ligne
particulièrement pour les jeunes filles
et nous avons organisé un colloque au
mois de novembre à cette occasion nous
avons eu des témoignages poignants de
victimes qui ont subi ce type de
violence sur les réseaux sociaux ou des
comptes sont créés dans le seul but de
diffuser des photos à l'insu des
personnes des vidéos intimes dénudées de
filles de femmes et de la même manière
des comptes sont créés et qui vise à
diffuser sans leur consentement bien
évidemment leur nom leur téléphone bref
leur identité est-ce que vous savez
comment s'appelle ces comptes tous ces
contes s'appelle des comptes dit ficha
et c'est une des nombreuses
cyber violence sexiste sexuel que
subissent majoritairement les femmes et
les jeunes filles et si peu d'entre nous
les connaissent
il paraît important que pour lutter
contre la ligne en la haine en ligne on
puisse nommer les choses monsieur le
rapporteur comment selon vous est-il
possible de lutter contre cette haine en
ligne je vous remercie merci madame la
députée Quentin bataillon
si madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur cher Président je souhaitais
vous aborder comme vous l'avez dit c'est
un sujet de société majeur qui est face
à nous et qui pose une question très
difficile ou jusqu'où la loi doit-elle
aller dans les familles doit-elle aller
dans les foyers
justement la position du groupe
Renaissance sur ce sujet et qu'on pense
qu'on doit déposséder l'autorité
parentale pour autant mais au contraire
donner justement à déjà de l'information
aux jeunes et aux parents mais aussi
donner les outils comme on l'avait fait
dans le cas de la PPL Studer avec le
contrôle parental donner des outils
justement en famille à la fois pour ne
pas les déposer mais leur permettre de
les aider justement sur ce sujet donc je
vous souhaitez connaître votre avis sur
ce juste équilibre entre effectivement
le besoin de légiférer de d'apporter du
soutien et de l'aide de famille mais
également ne pas les déposséder de leur
autorité et de leur pouvoir vis-à-vis de
leurs enfants
merci monsieur le député Ségolène Amiot
merci madame la Présidente
la charge de ce que leurs enfants
peuvent voir et faire sur les réseaux
sociaux quand on sait que 80% déclarent
l'ignorer les grands groupes numériques
ont créé des monstres qui ne contrôlent
plus cyber-harcèlement racisme n en
ligne pédocrinalité contenu ultra
violent
lgbtqia phobie sexisme fake news Revenge
porn etc
des phénomènes qui ont un impact d'une
violence extrême sur les jeunes esprits
et qui constituent aujourd'hui comme
vous le soulignez une problème de santé
publique et aboutit parfois à
l'irréparable c'est à nous élu de poser
un véritable cadre légal et opérationnel
et de contraindre ces entreprises à
respecter enfin et de à le respecter
enfin de et afin de protéger les mineurs
sur ces espaces numériques nos enfants
doivent être vus en tant que tel pas
comme des consommateurs cibles à rendre
accro sans véritable solution
opérationnelle vous proposer de laisser
les plateformes mettre en place leur
solution et expérimenter sous l'oeil de
l'arcome à contre-pied de l'urgence que
vous souligne alors avec tout le respect
que je vous dois monsieur le rapporteur
ne serait-il pas plus pertinent de
travailler collectivement sur ce sujet
et aboutir à un texte plus abouti
techniquement je vous remercie merci
madame la députée Annie Jeanne var
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
beaucoup de nos collègues ont évoqué les
dangers d'un usage illimité et non
contre les réseaux sociaux l'isolement
social la dépendance à l'écran la perte
de sommeil l'exposition prédateurs à la
pornographie le harcèlement scolaire
l'influence grandissante des
influenceurs donc je ne m'attarderai pas
sur ces points qui ont été déjà beaucoup
évoqués
la question que j'aurais vous poser
monsieur le rapporteur est la suivante
on ne cesse de légiférer
sous chaque législature nous légiférons
sur cette question de l'invasion des
réseaux sociaux de la haine en ligne et
la question que je me pose et de savoir
comment finalement c'est hyper
législation sur un sujet d'importance
nous oblige à aller toujours plus loin
mais l'événement puisque
on ne parvient pas à contrôler les
dérives de ces de l'usage de ces réseaux
sociaux quel est votre regard de
législateur sur le sujet
merci madame la députée Fabienne Colboc
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur votre proposition de loi
demande à son article 4 la rédaction
d'un rapport par le gouvernement sur les
conséquences de l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux sur le bien-être et la
santé mentale des jeunes notamment des
mineurs si votre proposition de loi se
consacre bien sur l'usage des réseaux
des réseaux sociaux élargir la demande
du rapport sur les conséquences des
plateformes en général permettrait de
prendre en compte notamment les
plateformes de vidéos utilisées comme
des réseaux sociaux pour les jeunes et
présentant de nombreux risques est-ce
que la demande de rapport de l'article 4
prendra-t-il en compte ces plateformes
numériques je vous remercie merci madame
la députée gradiez-la malkore
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
président Martin jelly je souhaite vous
remercier pour cette proposition de loi
en prévoyant l'interdiction des réseaux
sociaux au mineur jusqu'à 15 ans vous
apportez une réponse claire ferme qui
responsabilise tout à ta foi les réseaux
sociaux eux-mêmes mais également les
parents qui sont parfois un peu perdus
face à ce phénomène et aux conséquences
qui l'emportent sur leurs enfants
intimidation humiliation incitation à la
haine propagation de rumeurs les réseaux
sociaux sont un véritable vecteur
libérant chez les jeunes les pires
discriminations liées au racisme à une
identité de genre un handicap pour un
aspect physique entre 20 et 40% des
enfants selon les études disent avoir
été victimes de harcèlement phénomène
étonnant selon une chercheuse 72% des
cyber-harceleurs sont également des
cybers victimes alors je souhaiterais
que vous nous apportiez des détails sur
la manière dont votre proposition de loi
apporte des réponses supplémentaires
pour lutter contre ce phénomène qui a
déjà fait trop de victimes et je
voudrais profiter pour appeler chacun à
une plus grande vigilance enfant ou par
an victime ou témoins il existe un
numéro à contacter le 30 20
merci madame la députée Alexandre
portier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur Marc Angeli vous soulevez une
problématique fondamentale mes deux axes
semblent essentiels pour renforcer cette
proposition de loi à la fois la
cohérence juridique et en même temps
l'efficacité pratique et technique
cohérence juridique pourquoi ne pas
porter la majorité numérique à 16 ans
pour l'aligner sous la réglementation
européenne la lignée sur ce qui était la
position initiale de la France lors des
discussions sur le rgpd 16 ans étant
aussi je le rappelle la joue que
l'émancipation d'un jeune et
juridiquement possible saison
permettrait de mieux protéger les
données relatives aux jeunes jusqu'à cet
âge mais aussi de rappeler la
responsabilité parentale jusqu'à cet âge
l'objectif je crois que l'on partage et
puis efficacité pratique et technique
disais-je dans les amendements qui vont
suivre vous proposons la mise en place
d'une solution de vérification en ligne
via un tiers indépendant des réseaux
sociaux solutions techniques
effectivement qui ne seraient pas à
mettre en place dans le cas de légal
mais qui donnerait au ministre compétent
la possibilité de veiller à sa bonne
application à son évolution cette idée
manifestement partagée par le ministre
Jean-Noël barreau que nous avons
auditionné hier lors de la délégation en
droit des enfants donc je crois qu'on
peut trouver un point de consensus sur
ce sujet accepterez-vous cette
proposition de complément de votre texte
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député violet spielbou
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur je vous remercie pour cette
proposition de loi qui s'appuie sur le
principe d'une autorité parentale
réaffirmée et sur le contrôle parental
pour protéger nos enfants et nos jeunes
des dangers des réseaux sociaux
dépendance cyber-harcèlement chirurgie
esthétique anxiété suicide vous avez
insisté sur la sensibilisation des
parents et sur l'information pédagogique
nécessaire pour accompagner les enfants
à naviguer en toute sécurité vous avez
aussi insisté sur l'importance des
enjeux de santé publique de citoyenneté
et d'éducation pour l'ensemble des
familles et aussi pour les adultes en
formation pour demain on sait pourtant
que beaucoup de parents sont
complètement dépassés par les réseaux
sociaux au sein de leur propre famille
et aussi par les effets sur leurs
enfants
aussi comment comptez-vous rendre
réellement concret de cette loi
notamment l'affaire connaître aux
parents et en les rendant acteurs
éclairé face à ces défis des réseaux
sociaux comment comptez-vous vérifier
que les plateformes se mettront
réellement en ordre de marche pour
traiter les autorisations parentales je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
belkir Belhaddad merci madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues merci pour cette
proposition de loi qui a le mérite de
poser le débat dans le débat un vrai
sujet de société pour lequel vous tentez
d'apporter des réponses et je salue vous
propositions vous indiquez dans votre
rapport qui paraît difficile d'évaluer
le caractère raisonnable des efforts
engagés par les plateformes qui doivent
être s'il y a avec d'autres exigences
telles que la liberté d'expression la
protection des données à caractère
personnel et vous évoquez notamment
l'âge vous avez également mentionné à
juste titre dans l'article 4 les effets
néfastes d'un temps prolongé devant les
écrans on sait que la sédentarité
représente un mal dans notre société
représente un coup de près 17 milliards
d'euros le titre de la PPL précise la
lutte contre la haine en ligne et vous
proposer dans l'article 3 l'instauration
d'un délai de réponse aux réquisitions
judiciaire sous 48 heures en quoi cet
article et cette proposition pourrait
être efficace dans cette lutte contre la
haine sur le réseau sociaux ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il soit réduire ce
délai dans des circonstances d'une
certaine gravité on menaces imminente
merci merci monsieur le député Emmanuel
Antoine
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur votre proposition de loi
vise avant tout à protéger les mineurs
face aux dangers des réseaux numériques
et sur cet enchers je souhaiterais
revenir sur le
cyber-harcèlement en ligne nos enfants
qui acquièrent leur premier smartphone
de plus en plus tôt autour de l'âge de
10 ans sont plus précocément exposés au
cas de cyber-harcèlement pour tenter de
remédier à ce fléau il y a un an notre
Assemblée a permis l'adoption de la loi
visant à combattre le harcèlement
scolaire ce texte prévoit notamment de
renforcer les obligations des
plateformes numériques les acteurs
d'Internet site et fournisseurs d'accès
Internet sont ainsi censés modérer les
contenus de harcèlement scolaire sur les
réseaux sociaux et répondre à des
objectifs fixés que pouvez-vous nous
dire sur l'efficacité de cette loi qui
apparaît en lien direct avec le texte
que nous étudions aujourd'hui et
envisagez-vous des dispositions
permettant d'améliorer l'efficacité de
la contre le cyber-harcèlement scolaire
merci madame la députée car le livre
d'accord merci monsieur le député
Marie-Pierre fixe
merci madame la Présidente
le rapporteur
je ne vais pas revenir non plus sur les
dangers des réseaux sociaux je crois
qu'ils ont été suffisamment exprimés par
mes collègues et j'en partage évidemment
le constat vous dire tout simplement que
l'outil numérique ne semble être qu'un
accélérateur de haine comme toute
nouvelle outil de communication par
ailleurs il n'y a qu'à regarder
d'ailleurs l'état de de la haine qui
s'exprime dans notre société voire même
d'ailleurs dans nos débats
parlementaires je crois au contraire que
l'outil numérique peut être également et
vous l'avez dit un outil pour prendre
conscience également des réalités un
lieu également pour que les jeunes
puissent s'y exprimer leur solidarité un
lieu également d'échange pour eux je
crois que l'adolescence est un moment
également d'identification c'est un lieu
c'est un moment également où l'on peut
ressentir des stigmatisations où il y a
il peut y avoir également une haine qui
s'exprime à l'égard de la la différence
qu'elle soit une différence de genre une
différence d'origine sociale ou de toute
forme de par exemple du handicap
également et je crois qu'au contraire il
faut qu'on responsabilise aujourd'hui
les acteurs et ma question donc
s'adresse à vous c'est comment
comptez-vous responsabiliser les acteurs
de manière à ce qu'ils fassent de
l'outil numérique un outil vertueux
d'échanges et de communication pour
notre jeunesse
merci madame la députée monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole pour
répondre à nos collègues avant l'étude
des amendements
merci un certain nombre de questions
sont intrinsèquement liées à des
amendements qui seront déposés d'autres
sont plus à plus larges
donc Madame Riotton m'avez parlé de
comment lutter efficacement conseil en
ligne vous allez déposer un amendement
qui lui donnerait un avis favorable pour
compléter tout à l'heure le texte
je vous dirais que la loi ne peut pas
non plus tout dire et c'est aussi pour
répondre un peu à ma collègue à nigerva
la loi est là pour fixer un certain
nombre de câbles de précision limite de
cadres de bornes
mais ensuite je pense que nous avons
dans nos politiques publiques
des efforts à réaliser en matière de
prévention
en matière de prolongation de cette
éducation au milieu scolaire je vous
rappelle quand même que l'exposition aux
écrans c'est aussi un sujet scolaire
aujourd'hui et la première fois parfois
que un enfant se retrouve avec une
tablette
quelque chose qui a allié avec le
numérique ça peut être à l'école et
c'est à l'école donc il a nécessité
d'éducation la lutte contre la haine en
ligne c'est une question d'éducation
aussi d'où encore une fois
la question de la responsabilité
parentale qui me semble essentielle
c'est l'un des cœurs de cette
proposition de loi je souhaite
véritablement c'est le cœur de cette
proposition de doigts mettre le parent
au cœur du dispositif et ensuite la
lutte contre la haine en ligne ça va par
aussi par
créer les mécanismes de sanction les
faire respecter il y a les questions par
rapport au délai de réponse qui ont été
évoqués tout à l'heure par rapport aux
saisines des autorités j'ai mis le
curseur sur 48 heures parce que
j'estimais que il y a d'autres priorités
par exemple pour l'effet de terrorisme
il y a des délais qui sont beaucoup plus
brefs qui sont demandés aux opérateurs
de réseaux sociaux on aurait pu mettre
plus large également et vous avez la
différence entre une enquête de
flagrance et la différence entre une
information judiciaire ou une
instruction ou ce qu'on peut donner aux
autorités compétentes peut être fait
dans un délai plus long donc lutter
contre l'année en ligne et bien tout
simplement voilà je vous dis c'est se
doter d'un certain nombre de d'outils
qui ne sont pas que dans la loi je le
dis encore parce que tout ne peut pas
être dans la loi mais qui soit également
dans les pratiques et dans les
politiques publiques que nous menons
mais également dans l'éveil des
consciences et c'est bien le but
d'ailleurs je le dis de de loi essayer
de le communiquer au maximum pour
éveiller davantage encore les
consciences sur les dangers et sur les
réponses qu'on peut apporter et il faut
rappeler ce qui a déjà été fait encore
une fois oui mais ce matin on l'a
rappelé il y a les lois qui sont déjà
passées et
je vous l'ai dit c'est une brique moi
j'ai pas
vocation aujourd'hui à vous régler le
problème seul et vous m'accompagnez pour
rendre le texte meilleur et demain il y
aura je le pense d'autres initiatives
parce que on parle d'un monde qui est un
mouvement permanent
donc il y a pas
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de recette
miracle en revanche il a des principes
qu'il faut rappeler en faisant de la
politique et moi en ce sens un débat sur
une niche parlementaire c'est aussi
rappeler des principes et des valeurs
simple et leur donner corps à travers
une proposition de loi
[Musique]
vous savez pourquoi parce que au moment
où nous parlons vous avez des avancées
des accélérations notamment sur la
pornographie où on devrait normalement
avoir des réponses assez rapidement ça a
été annoncé dans la presse mais moi ce
que j'ai voulu fixer et ce que je pense
qu'il faut fixer à chaque fois dans le
marbre de la loi c'est les principes
c'est les rappeler c'est-à-dire à quel
âge pas avant pas après et ensuite les
modalités techniques il faut laisser
ceux qui sont le mieux placés pour
pouvoir les les définir sous contrôle là
toujours naturellement et également
mettre les organismes de contrôle parce
qu'il y en a en France sur le sujet
après le décret en Conseil d'État qui
viendrait compléter
sur
collègue à Ali Genevard voilà oui mon
regard de législateur effectivement vous
avez vous avez une législation qui est
abondante mais mais c'est dire mais
c'est dire c'est dire la place que ça
prend dans nos vies quotidiennes et
moi je sais pas ce que viendra la loi la
modeste loi que je dépose encore une
fois je vous dis c'est pas une œuvre une
oeuvre à titre personnel moi ce que je
veux c'est faire avancer le sujet d'un
esprit des Françaises et des Français
saisir les consciences rappeler à sa
nombre de principes et de valeur parce
que ce que ce qu'est l'exosquelette de
cette proposition de loi c'est le rappel
d'un certain nombre de principes et de
valeur de limitation de
responsabilisation mais également
d'informations donc c'est c'est le but
et effectivement j'espère que nous
serons en capacité dans les années à
venir
d'avoir un arsenal législatif qui sera
pas
suivi
d'autres lois trop nombreuses trop
bavardes parce que effectivement au-delà
de ce sujet là le problème de la
multiplication des textes législatives
dans notre pays je suis pas besoin de
vous le rappeler est un vrai sujet
politique majeur
sur Madame colvoc l'article 4
effectivement vous avez en discuter dans
le cadre de d'un amendement qui a été
déposé en ce sens
qui a qui qui pose la question comme
vous l'avez dit de l'élargissement de
cette enquête que je souhaite voir
réaliser sous les gîtes de l'État alors
moi j'ai essayé de choisir mes combats
en fait en réalité à travers cette
proposition de loi et comme je l'ai dit
j'ai voulu recentrer sur le sujet
réseaux sociaux parce que j'aurais pu
comme d'autres de mes collègues on
pensait le faire et où l'ont déjà fait
ouvrir d'autres horizons président du
groupe horizon ça tombe bien sur le
champ de l'étude moi vraiment les
réseaux sociaux m'interroge
sur la pratique mais attention ça veut
pas dire que j'ai pas reçu d'autres
opérateurs importants j'ai reçu YouTube
par exemple qui pose aussi une question
puis on peut se poser également les
questions des messageries
qui créent également mais je n'ai pas
voulu ouvrir trop le champ
de gérer d'exploration chez vous le
recentrer sur ces fameuses plateformes
de réseaux sociaux que vous connaissez
tous que nous pratiquons presque tous et
qui à mon avis doivent être l'enjeu donc
je répondrai tout à l'heure à
l'argumentation qui est la vôtre dans le
cadre de la défense de l'amendement mais
je pense que on peut cheminer madame
Melchior mais oui la protection des
enfants
il faut l'assurer et et je le dis encore
une fois la loi seule ne peut pas
l'assurer
c'est une oeuvre humaine aussi qui doit
qui doit qui doit se poursuivre en
dehors des textes de loi ça se passe à
l'école ça se passe ça se passe dans les
dans les maisons dans les familles
voilà c'est une question de société et
cette protection elle peut être aussi
technique on peut demander aux
opérateurs de renforcer les mécanismes
d'appel à l'aide
aussi je sais qu'il y a des progrès qui
ont été réalisés ces dernières années de
signalement mais il faut contraindre à
ce que ces signalements soient suivi des
faits et il faut également je le dis
encore c'est vraiment un enjeu majeur de
la loi rappelé aux parents à quel point
ce qui se passe à tout tout à côté d'eux
peut être décisif et grave
la réalité c'est que avec un smartphone
dans le même maison
sous le même foyer parfois dans la même
pièce
et bien vous avez un gosse qui fait
quelque chose son père ou sa mère est à
côté et ils ne savent pas ce qui se
passe et ça je veux le rappeler et c'est
aussi cette sensibilisation là que je
veux aller chercher
alors sur l'âge je vais essayer de
répondre quand même aux questions parce
que 16 ans c'est un vrai sujet il y aura
des amendements pour peut-être j'y
viendrai parce que j'ai
sur la ça débat qui est Madame Antoine a
déposé d'amendements vous poser la
question
fallait choisir vous avez la possibilité
de 16 ans effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit il y avait celle de 15 ans
celle de 15 ans elle est
[Musique]
suggéré elle est suggérer par des
conventions que nous avons passé et par
un certain nombre un certain nombre de
choses et puis j'ai choisi
volontairement l'âge de la majorité
sexuelle je vous explique pourquoi parce
que même si
on a d'autres majorités la plus
importante est en 18 ans 16 ans ça fait
aussi penser à la conduite accompagnée
par exemple
je pense que l'âge de 15 ans aimait bien
il faudrait pas non plus à travers l'âge
qu'on va choisir
donner une impression
je dirais
où on va infantiliser parce que ça se
sent aussi vous êtes au lycée
vous passez dans une nouvelle génération
vous n'êtes plus au collège je crois
qu'il y a il y a une petite nuance à
apporter ça aurait pu être 16 ans aussi
ça aurait pu être 13 puisque certains
disent considérés que c'était 13 mois 13
je considère que ça peut être trop jeune
il y a des amendements qui seront
déposés qui seront débattus
j'expliquerai vraiment pourquoi j'ai
choisi 16 ans mais je vous donne déjà
un aperçu de ma réflexion
sur les délais d'abord les techniques de
contrôle j'en ai parlé madame Sibout il
y a ça nous échappe je pense je pense
que ces techniques de contrôle c'est
pour ça que je renvoie au Conseil d'État
des crépus bien Conseil d'État on peut
pas aujourd'hui le préciser
de manière
solide dans la loi c'est pour ça que je
souhaite je souhaite renvoyer par
rapport à ce qui est fait par ailleurs
notamment pour lutter contre l'accès
voilà pornographie peut avoir des
éléments qui se complètent et je renvoie
encore sur les fournisseurs d'accès
c'est important d'avoir la réflexion sur
les fournisseurs d'accès
sur la réduction des délais mon cher
collègue oui voilà je vous l'ai dit la
réduction des délais on a essayé d'être
le plus proportionné possible avec le
délai qui est proposé pour répondre aux
réquisitions judiciaire
sur l'efficacité de la loi en cours sur
le cyber-harcèlement en ligne madame
Antoine et bien je vous dirais que je
n'ai pas l'évaluation complète des
politiques publiques telles qu'elles
existent aujourd'hui en tête concernant
l'arsenal législatif déjà de nos
dispositions concernant la lutte contre
la harcèlement en ligne j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir des auditions avec
des associations et des responsables
secteurs ça progresse ça progresse on
est sorti d'un peu du no man's land dans
lequel on se trouvait mais il reste
encore malheureusement et on le voit
beaucoup d'efforts à réaliser et
beaucoup de progrès à faire et ensuite
la responsabilisation des acteurs madame
rixin bien je vous dirais que la
responsabilisation des acteurs
malheureusement on en vient toujours au
même point il y a que la peur de
l'Ascension qui a qui fait la différence
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il faut se doter
des moyens de pouvoir faire respecter un
minimum minimum de règles et surtout de
s'assurer que pas de respect de règles
égales sanction je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur la
discussion générale est close donc nous
allons pouvoir passer à l'examen des
amendements et chers collègues vous
allez pouvoir vous exprimer parce que
j'entends bien que vous avez vraiment
envie de vous exprimer ce matin donc
nous sommes saisis d'environ une
quarantaine d'amendements donc nous
allons commencer par le premier qui est
un amendement du rapporteur l'amendement
41 merci madame la Présidente c'est un
endroit qui a qui a
reprend l'article premier et je vois je
propose avec cet amendement d'ancré la
définition des réseaux sociaux dans la
loi 2004 pour la confiance dans
l'économie numérique plutôt que dans le
Code des postes et communication
électronique
la CPCE cirque est-ce que c'est un
amendement de réécriture donc si vous ce
serait bien qu'on s'écoute tous merci
beaucoup merci le CP ce défi le régime
applicable aux communication
électronique et confie à l'ARCEP la
régulation d'un secteur cette autorité
n'a pas vocation à réguler les réseaux
sociaux cette compétence revenant à la
com cette définition est issue du
Règlement sur les marchés numériques du
DMA les règlements sont d'applications
directes et la transposition de la
définition pourrait donc sembler
superflu cependant il n'est pas certain
que la définition des réseaux sociaux du
DMA évocation à s'appliquer au-delà du
règlement du point de vue de la sécurité
juridique il était donc préférable de
disposer d'une définition dans la loi
d'aller donc le l'objet le projet projet
de de cet amendement donc voilà je suis
revenu sur le caractère protéiforme de
du réseau social dans les discussions
que nous avons eu
tous n'ont pas le même objet la même
finalité le même degré de publicité
selon le cas il peut toujours être
difficile de qualifier une plateforme de
réseau social ou non
et si vous souhaitez en savoir plus je
vous renvoie l'excellente étude annuelle
du Conseil d'État qui a longuement
traité de la question de la définition
même du réseau social il convenait donc
de retenir une définition large ce qu'a
fait l'Union européenne avec le DMA
cette définition me paraît pour ma part
satisfaisante j'ai donc souhaité la
transcrire telle qu'elle dans la loi
merci monsieur
la parole même si mes collègues ont été
plus précis que moi mes collègues de
groupe en remercions le rapporteur sur
la pertinence du sujet mais
il y a un problème c'est que
la manière dont vous répondez monsieur
le rapporteur exprime j'ai une mesurer
une impuissance totale quoi on se
demande au bout d'un moment dans quelle
mesure
d'efficacité de ce qui existe déjà dans
la loi peut se mettre en application et
vous-même semblez dire qu'en fait on n'y
peut rien le fond du sujet reste quand
même les sanctions qui sont infligées à
ces plateformes
et votre texte est assez silencieux
là-dessus pour qu'il y ait des sanctions
des sanctions qui soient significatives
enfin je voudrais terminer sur une chose
pour aller vite c'est que
le nombre d'heures qu'un enfant passe
sur les réseaux et aujourd'hui au moins
équivalent voir plus sur une année en
tant qu'il passe dans l'éducation
nationale il y a un déséquilibre total
entre l'outil que nous avons pour
transmettre une éducation à nos enfants
l'éducation nationale et la puissance de
ces plateformes et donc le sujet aussi
ce serait de quelle manière l'éducation
nationale se saisit du sujet là beaucoup
de mots sont dit sur les parents mais je
voudrais pas qu'on culpabilise les
parents sur des choses face auxquelles
souvent ils sont totalement
désarmés et donc qu'un discours à la fin
qui consiste à dire parents surveiller
vos enfants alors que bien souvent les
parents n'ont aucune éducation aucune
connaissance c'est à nous d'aider les
enfants merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc juste pour bien comprendre votre
avis sur ce sous amendement
et contre
j'étais plutôt favorable sous un moment
je voulais réagir sur la réponse du
rapporteur qui me semblait manifester
quelque chose qui déshabillait
complètement son texte vous êtes
favorable à ce moment monsieur bataillon
merci madame la Présidente donc je vous
confirme aussi pour le groupe
Renaissance à la vie défavorable cet
amendement bien sûr on remercie à notre
collègue Béatrice Piron et sur message
effectivement est très clair mais on
pense qu'effectivement ce n'est pas
opérant comme l'a dit le rapporteur et
on souhaite pas totalement dépossédé non
plus les parents aussi de leur autorité
c'est quelque chose qui est important
pour nous et puis pour répondre à la
française soumise les sanctions sont
bien présentes puisqu'elles font l'objet
justement de cet article 2 et on
remercie le rapporteur de d'avoir été
ferme sur ce point là
merci donc je vais mettre au voie ce
sous amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre
le sous amendement et rejeté le sous
amendement numéro 48 madame Piron merci
madame la Présidente se présente
maintenant vise à permettre aux parents
de demander la suppression du compte de
leur enfant mineur sur un réseau social
puisqu'il conserve l'autorité parentale
jusqu'à la majorité civile de l'enfant
les mineurs de plus de 15 ans la
possibilité de s'inscrire sur les
réseaux sociaux sans accord parental
préalable car c'est considéré comme un
acte courant de la vie toutefois
l'autorité parentale s'exerçant jusqu'à
la majorité civile de l'enfant les
parents conservent la possibilité si le
souhaite d'exiger la suppression du
compte de l'enfant même si ce compte a
été créé sans leur accord préalable
merci madame la députée monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis
merci madame la Présidente aujourd'hui
un mineur de plus de 15 ans peut
s'inscrire seul sur les réseaux sociaux
en consentant de façon autonome au
traitement de ces données personnelles
la France a un effet choisie ce
seuildage pour déclencher cette
possibilité laisser au mineur vous savez
relativement asymétrique de permettre
cette inscription seule si c'est pour
ensuite donner tout moyen au détenteurs
de l'autorité parentale de la révoquer
sans que les motifs de cette demande ne
puissent être soumis à contradiction
avec le mineur concerné
je pense que nous devons avoir en tête
que ce seuil de 15 ans entendu comme le
seuil de maturité numérique permettant
une inscription autonome et qui
correspond à l'entrée au lycée
correspond aussi à un âge d'adolescent
parfois conflictuel avec les parents
devons-nous vraiment permettre à tout
parents de disposer de cette option de
faire fermer les comptes de mineur sans
que celui-ci ne puisse s'y opposer il y
a selon moi un vrai enjeu
d'acceptabilité sociale et de placement
de curseur
je pense qu'à tout le mois une telle
possibilité mais être un travail
d'examen plus approfondi qui serait donc
à ce stade défavorable mais pas
totalement désintéressé parce que vous
avez dit Madame
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
rapporteur donc j'ai une demande de j'ai
deux demandes de prise de parole donc
d'abord monsieur Arenas et en fonction
de bataillon puisque je ne sais pas
ce sera pas il y a une sorte de de
contradiction dans l'exposé des motifs
et du coup sur le votre défavorable
incité par rapporteur ce terme non
puisque précisément l'autorité parentale
signifie que le c'est le parent qui
décide donc dès lors il y a il y a une
injonction contradictoire c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que les parents
étant responsable de leur enfance
évidemment eux qui leur donnent le libre
accès aussi à des choses qui ne relève
pas de leur compétences en tant que
mineur ensuite comme le disait mon
collègue Corbière il y a un sujet aussi
par rapport à l'école étant donné que au
collège puisque c'est cette tranche
d'âge que nous visons l'école incite les
enfants et les parents à utiliser les
outils numériques et parmi eux des
réseaux sociaux je tiens à rappeler
quand même que pendant le covid de
nombreux enseignants ont utilisé les
réseaux sociaux et l'utilise toujours au
moment où nous parlons pour communiquer
avec les familles pour communiquer les
enfants sur des intérêts pédagogiques et
éducatifs et parfois annexes donc il
faudrait faire attention à déposséder
les parents de leur autorité parentale
mais aussi s'interroger sur le rôle que
je l’école sur l'incitation
contradictoire ce que nous en train
d'étudier aujourd'hui enfin pour
terminer je voudrais attirer votre
attention aussi sur le fait que les
serveurs qui hébergent les réseaux
sociaux pour beaucoup sont aux
États-Unis et dans des pays qui sont
soumis législation qui nous échappent
par exemple le patriotact aujourd'hui la
législation américaine notamment celle
des États-Unis
par rapport au droit français par
rapport à l'utilisation et la protection
des données et cela il n'est pas dans
lequel nous étudions aujourd'hui mais
qui devrait faire l'objet je pense de
discussion future merci monsieur le
député donc
c'est vous avez argumenté mais par
rapport aux sous amendements
j'ai commencé par dire que nous
voterions pour un
mais c'était pas forcément très clair
donc c'est pour ça
que franchement les débuts de les débuts
de fromage ils entendent pas forcément
c'est peut-être aussi dû au rhume que
j'ai aujourd'hui mais voilà donc c'est
pour ça donc je vais mettre aux voix ce
sous non mais monsieur bataillon ne vous
souhaite plus prendre la parole
puisqu'il est pour aussi donc c'est pour
ça
monsieur le rapporteur donc votre avis
sur cet amendement vous ai dit c'est
défavorable plutôt défavorable même si
je reconnais c'est plutôt des sens de ce
qui est proposé à travers cet amendement
je continue quand même de penser que il
faut essayer de passer le curseur de la
manière la plus équilibrée qui soit donc
ce sous amendement qui a reçu un avis
plutôt défavorable du rapporteur qui est
pour
qui contre
cet amendement est adopté nous passons
sous amendement numéro 50
oui madame la Présidente que je vais
présenter avec
le si vous le voulez bien ces
amendements vise à permettre d'infliger
une amende plus importante en cas de non
respect de l'obligation de vérification
de l'âge des utilisateurs finaux et du
consentement dû ou des titulaires de
l'autorité parentale cet amende pourra
atteindre 1% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial du fournisseur de services de
réseaux sociaux
une telle sanction permettra de mieux
prendre en compte mieux prendre en
compte la taille de l'entreprise afin de
rendre véritablement opérante la
coercition souhaitée comme l'exposé des
motifs l'a évoqué les réseaux sociaux
ont un impact important sur la santé
mentale des jeunes face à de tels enjeux
il importe de prévoir un dispositif plus
ambitieux avec des sanctions à mon avis
plus importantes en outre l'amendement
50 raccourcit le délai d'entrée en
vigueur du dispositif de contrôle du
respect de l'obligation faite aux
opérateurs de plateforme en ligne de
faire respecter la majorité numérique le
délai d'un an apparaît trop long il
convient de le raccourcir à 6 mois ce
qui laissera suffisamment de temps aux
plateformes pour s'adapter
merci madame la députée monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis
oui merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement donc propose une amende à
hauteur de 1% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial j'ai souhaité comme indiqué dans
le rapport provisoire qui vous a été
transmis hier faire évoluer ma démarche
dans un double souci de bonne
articulation avec le droit de l'Union
européenne et le respect du principe de
proportionnalité après réflexion il
m'est apparu que la main de 1% du
chiffre d'affaires que je proposais à
l'article 3 risquez d'être considéré
comme disproportionné plusieurs
personnes auditionnées ainsi que le
gouvernement m'ont alerté sur ce risque
et je les ai donc rejoint et donc choisi
d'aligner l'article 3 sur la peine d'un
an d'emprisonnement et 250000 euros
d'amende prévue par la LCL
je ne peux donc pas accepter une telle
demande une dans le cadre de l'article 2
s'agissante d'entrée en vigueur de la
procédure de sanction je pense qu'il
faut laisser le temps à l'arcom et la
CNIL de développer le référentiel d'une
part et donner un délai aux réseaux
sociaux pour s'adapter à la nouvelle
obligation de l'être six mois que vous
proposez me semble particulièrement
court donc avis défavorable pour le
premier et le deuxième sous amendement
merci monsieur le député leur rapporteur
donc je vais mettre au voie ces sous
amendements qui ont reçu la vie
défavorable du rapporteur donc pour
l'amendement numéro le sous amendement
numéro 50 qui est pour
qui est contre le sous amendement est
rejeté le sous amendement numéro 49
je le mets aux voix qui pour
qui contre
il est adopté
donc maintenant je vais mettre au bois
l'amendement 42
du rapporteur ainsi modifié qui est pour
qui est contre
l'amendement
et l'amendement ainsi modifié est adopté
et donc l'article 2 ainsi rédigé est
adopté donc les autres amendements
exposés après l'article 2 tombe donc
nous passons directement à l'amendement
numéro 17 de Madame Amiot
oui
vous avez tellement bien travaillé avec
la entre la réécriture et des sous
amendements vous avez tellement bien
travaillé qu'effectivement c'est en fait
tomber quelques-uns donc Madame abiot
c'est bon pour le numéro 17 voilà donc
il est affiché autrement si vous le
souhaitez
merci madame la Présidente pour cet
amendement nous proposons que les
entreprises de services de réseaux
sociaux en ligne soit légalement tenu de
procéder à un traitement par une
personne humaine
lorsqu'un contenu est signalé par un
mineur ou concerne un mineur l'idée
étant simple de ne pas mettre en place
une censure a priori par un algorithme
mais bien que lorsqu'il s'agit lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un mineur ou d'un signe de la
donc de la part d'un signalement d'un
mineur ou concernant un mineur qu'il y
ait bien un avis humain sur la question
ça rappelle et ça renvoie à certaines
choses notamment sur les définitions de
la pornographie je ne saurais la définir
mais je sais quand j'en vois
nous ne pouvons pas à mon avis et je
crois que c'est le c'est la vie de mon
groupe aussi nous ne pouvons pas
sous-traiter cette activité à une
machine il est impératif qu'un œil
humain puisse puisse s'approprier les
questions de signalement et aviser de
savoir si un enfant est en danger ou non
il est il est vraiment primordial que
qu'un humain s'occupe de cette tâche
merci madame la députée monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis même si je
comprends le sens de la démarche
je pense que des difficultés engendrées
par la technicité des vérifications
d'âge et des critères proposés ils sont
larges et d'applications trop complexes
il ferait je pense porter sur les
entreprises les opérateurs des
obligations qui sont très difficiles à
tenir eu égard à la massification des
données
dont nous parlons donc je comprends
cette volonté mais je donne un avis
défavorable
monsieur Arenas oui pour des fonds
par rapport à l'arrivée des algorithmes
et de ce qu'on appelle plus largement
l'intelligence artificielle il y a
qu'aujourd'hui la technologie et en
train de nous déposséder de l'importance
de l'humanité dans les entreprises qui
se mettent en place sur le numérique je
vais prendre un exemple qui sort de ce
champ là aujourd'hui les les grandes
entreprises et les PME maintenant
utilisent des algorithmes pour trier les
CV c'est à dire que si demain nous avons
sur notre historique
numérique des malveillances des
dénonciations calomnieuses ou alors pire
des articles de presse qui s'avéreraient
faux à terme et bien un employeur futur
parce que ça sera traité par des
algorithmes votre CV notre CV le CV de
nos constitué n'arrivera pas sur le
bureau du RH donc ce qui se passe au
niveau des enfants et que nous étudions
aujourd'hui par rapport à des risques
dramatiques comme la pénal comme la
pédoporn pornographie pardon le
harcèlement etc est aussi valable
au-delà du champ de l'école et je pense
que ce que nous faisons avec les enfants
aujourd'hui ce nous avons à discuter
légiférer à une influence au-delà de la
sphère de de la maturité de la de des
parents donc c'est de cela dont nous
discutons et je pense que cet argument
que des formes à mieux tout à fait
recevable merci monsieur le député
monsieur bataillon merci la Présidente
je vais bien rester sur le sujet de
l'amendement pour ma part juste je
comprends tout à fait la volonté de
notre collègue madame Amiot je pense
qu'elle a raison dans le sens où
effectivement qui est on va dire un oeil
humain pour superviser est important
pour autant un premier travail en tout
cas d'intelligence artificielle
essentielle à la fois pour que ce soit
opérant et ensuite pour que ce soit
rapide et vraiment efficace donc
peut-être voir d'ici la séance on peut
retravailler sur voilà le fait qu'un
contrôle une supervision derrière mais
une première étape en intelligence
artificielle permettra de rendre les
choses à la fois opérante efficace donc
défavorable à cet amendement merci
monsieur le député je vais mettre aux
voix cet amendement qui a reçu la vie
défavorable du rapporteur qui pour
qui contre
l'amendement est rejeté l'amendement
numéro 22 de Madame Amiot
toujours sur le même sujet l'idée est de
de laisser aux entreprises
qui au service de réseaux sociaux 48
heures pour pour répondre à un
signalement concernant un mineur ou émis
par un mineur
merci madame la députée monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis le droit français
comme le droit au Périn contiennent déjà
des dispositions sur la protection des
mineurs et sur le cyber-harcèlement le
DSA notamment imposé aux plateformes de
traité en priorité notification soumise
par les signalures de confiance et de
traiter dans les meilleurs délais je
vous vois les guillemets l'association
il y a enfance que j'ai rencontré par
exemple était reconnu signaler de
confiance
l'article 16 du DSA impose également aux
plateformes la mise en place de
mécanismes de notification et d'action
destinées à signaler aux plateformes des
contenus illicites la plateforme de
notifié dans les meilleurs délaisses à
décision à la personne auteur du
signalement et traitée notification en
temps opporta et de manière diligente
s'agissant plus spécifiquement des
mineurs le DSA a introduit l'obligation
pour les plateformes en ligne de prendre
des mesures appropriées et
proportionnées pour garantir la sûreté
et la sécurité des mineurs sur leurs
services le DSA est d'application
directe et nous devons veiller à la
bonne articulation entre ces règles et
notre législation il n'impose pas de
délai pour répondre à ces signalement
enfin
je pense que délai de 48 heures et
l'amende de 6% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial ne respecte pas le principe de
proportionnalité la loi pour la
confiance dans l'économie numérique
qu'une dernière emprisonnement de 250000
euros d'amende le fait de ne pas
satisfaire à l'obligation de lutte
contre la diffusion de contenu illicite
via des dispositifs de signalement avis
défavorable merci Monsieur le rappeurs
le rapporteur je pense que vous avez
bien fait d'amander votre votre texte
initial effectivement il est en ce sens
plus précis pour autant
pour autant encore une fois dans
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant avoir
une sanction qui soit non pas justement
qui puisse paraître disproportionné
serait fortement incitatrice et là
vraiment j'insiste là dessus avoir une
sanction qui serait de l'argent de poche
pour des gafams
ne revêtraient finalement
qu'un
viendrait à faillir complètement ce
texte ne pas ne pas prendre en compte
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant est des
enfants de façon générale et du coup du
moins faire le choix pour une entreprise
de ne pas de ne pas s'y tarder serait à
mon sens
dramatique puisque finalement ce serait
un coup d'épée dans l'eau vis-à-vis de
ce texte donc je pense vraiment qu'il
est important de de repenser les choses
en termes de sanction non pas en termes
de proportionnalité mais de quel but on
souhaite atteindre
merci madame la députée
il n'y a pas d'autres reprises de parole
donc je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement du rapporteur qui est pour
qui contre
l'amendement est adopté donc comme cette
amendement est adopté comme vous l'a dit
le rapporteur il fait tomber les
suivants donc nous passons maintenant
l'article ainsi
3 insérer les autres amendements tombent
donc maintenant nous passons
un amendement numéro 31 de l'article 4
madame Colboc
merci madame la Présidente alors nous
manquons à ce jour de donner sur les
conséquences de l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux par les jeunes et
notamment des mineurs cependant élargir
la demande de rapport au gouvernement
sur les conséquences de l'utilisation
des plateformes en général et non pas
uniquement sur les réseaux sociaux
permettrait de prendre en compte
certaines plateformes supplémentaires
notamment les plateformes vidéo très
utilisées par les jeunes or sur ces
plateformes vidéo les jeunes peuvent
être la cible de prédateurs sexuels et
de cyber-harcèlement notamment la prise
en compte comme le propos s'est
amendement de toutes les plateformes
dans ce rapport permettrait d'évaluer la
maîtrise et la conscience de l'image des
jeunes en ligne je vous remercie merci
madame la députée monsieur le rapporteur
votre avis d'abord je rejoins votre
constat c'est que les données sur les
conséquences de l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux sont insuffisantes c'est
pour ça que je propose dans cet article
ce rapport j'en ai longuement parlé je
pense notamment au comparaison qui
reviennent souvent dans le débat public
par rapport à l'addiction aux drogue
puisque il faut mettre le sujet sur la
table on peut également parfois voir un
comportement de type addictif vis-à-vis
de l'utilisation de réseaux sociaux ces
études scientifiques ont été réalisées
mais tout cela est encore assez
embryonnaire j'ai souhaité dans le cadre
de cette proposition focaliser mon
attention sur les réseaux sociaux ce ne
sont pas les seules plateformes pouvant
présenter des risques pour les mineurs
ni créer des dépendances j'en conviens
mais c'est l'approche que j'ai retenue
dans cette activité parlementaire comme
dans la vie de tous les jours il faut
savoir choisir ses combats et cibler ce
qu'on veut mener par ailleurs YouTube ou
twitch sont bien considérés comme des
réseaux sociaux si ma proposition de loi
est adoptée en ce sens la définition de
l'articles premiers à mon sens est
suffisamment large donc je donne un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
je vais mettre au bois cet amendement
qui a reçu un avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre
l'amendement est adopté
donc je l'amendement numéro 27 madame
spielbou
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur dans cet article 4 je propose
d'ajouter la phrase de la surinformation
et de l'exposition aux fausses
informations en parlant des risques des
réseaux sociaux concernés par le rapport
qui est proposé à cet article 4 pourquoi
parce que on a déjà beaucoup parlé des
conséquences néfastes de la
surinformation de la surconsommation
d'information et des fake news sur le
rapport des jeunes à la citoyenneté aux
valeurs de la République et cela crée
une défiance dans les médias voire même
du complotisme parfois et puis on a
parlé aussi des conséquences néfastes
sur la santé mentale vous avez parlé de
dépendance mais on peut aller jusqu'à
l'anxiété la dépression la défiance
envers l'avenir et envers nos
institutions donc il me semble important
de pouvoir rajouter ces notions dans cet
article je vous remercie merci Madame la
député monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
merci d'après madame la député les les
réseaux sociaux c'est vrai on en a parlé
dans les propos liminaires et
je crois que ça fait souvent le
buzz dans la formation en règle générale
ils sont vecteurs de fausses
informations de manière permanente je
suis conscient j'ai d'ailleurs consacré
à ce problème une partie entière de
l'avant-propos de ce rapport et j'hésite
notamment une étude de lifop qui a été
réalisée en 2022 qui a solidement
démontré que les jeunes utilisateurs de
réseaux sociaux sont plus susceptibles
d'adhérer à certaines théories et des
fausses informations en général que ceux
qui n'en utilisent pas c'est important
de le savoir nous disposons déjà de
donner sur ce point mais il est
nécessaire d'y voir plus clair cependant
la rédaction actuelle de l'article 4
tel quel me semble suffisamment large
pour inclure tous les dangers des
réseaux sociaux sur la santé des mineurs
fausses informations comprises on voit
sans être soit un avis défavorable je
pense que c'est déjà couvert par le
champ d'application cet article 4
notamment aussi concerne les ce qu'on
appelle encore en anglais fake news
donc je vais mettre au bois
la proposition de loi qui est pour
qui est contre
[Rires]